[Music]
was of you we laugh rolling start Kirby
yeah when I press the but I'm not like
King I don't come into a beat
so it to a beat so it's okay when I went
online you know what's going on
squirrely dan was going on Wilhelm
scream the scream is in the building
Cory Moseley what's up you know was
going on the - oh man Iago Python okay
okay cat daddy happy oh happy Father's
Day you already know Shawn what's going
on let me know I heard attic interrupted
I know y'all heard attics I shouldn't
even have to ask you out for a mic check
right quick eras summers what's going on
bro I'll be appreciating the love so let
me know yeah I can hear everybody good
and crisp and everything I was leaving
you know - man no more bear for you this
was a coffee what we doing coffee mr.
glass and sir shroom kingdom was going
on Virg brizl yeah you already know this
is Sunday spot scream gun Dan what's up
JD what up
oh thank you thank you since audio
sounds good
I suppose go chill what's going on Nina
no a back room and we all live all using
my say isn't like that she's know what
up on we go just chill out for a minute
wait for the king then we waited for um
Dan all the good people to come through
as well do a little my oh we got the lap
o in the building hola that's what I'm
talking about the lap Oh
potentially perfect coming outside we
need to see more you so we go see out a
bit we gonna meal come back wait for the
King cuz the king will be in here to get
us copyright strike any second now so we
will seek out a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then watching music with the fallout
of super chat salute
thank you brother much appreciated your
ain't no Facebook I see you in a
building mixed I see you in a building
John sterling I see you in the building
what's going on thank you for that we
definitely gonna have a lot to talk
about that wait for Dan they've rolled
up he should be here any minute and then
the king will be here soon so see out a
bit we're going today come in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Mic Check Mic Check like we got the
whole gang in the building trucker hat
hollow says attic I thought you said I
better see the glorious outfit a little
Mic Check make sure I can hear everybody
on din I had to talk to the people saw
my check put up a note that it sounds
low addict talk talk of the year Sam oh
yeah a little bit yeah go closer so keep
talking I mean I'm pretty close to our
graph except I'm good
all right cool cool King what the people
know that's hard cuz that sound better
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh we live we love happy patriarchs day
hey don't salute all amazing fathers out
there in the realm make sure you enjoy
your day and welcome to the iron Lords
podcast and the Lords of gaming dotnet
episode number 163 and it's another
glorious Sunday we're back at the
roundtable and the Lord's Day I'm very
excited about our special guests and
we've got last of us to non-spoiler
impressions cyberpunk 2077 delayed again
and Playstation 5 price points to
discuss so we gonna get right into it I
want to introduce the Lord whose
tremendous passion for gaming are only
matched by his hilarious takes on the
video game industry now is this Lord
part of a seasoned group who values
journalistic integrity but he is also a
true og who gravitates towards the best
console experiences introducing the
senior contributor of seasoned gaming
calm and the co-host of the big cast the
Lord of the most hilarious takes on
Twitter and after the ps4's recent
reveal has skyrocketed to bugs taxes
number one spin from Kansas City and
making his debut into the realm of the
Lord's mommy Lord and Rodriguez how you
doing sir
yeah I am doing awesome it's so awesome
to be on the show guys I have watched
him forever and so it's like as a fan
this is you know kind of like one of
those little dreams come true you know
be able talking up it's awesome salute
aside the beer solo been good to have
you been logo doing bottarga for a while
had to get another one of the season
lords in here man what you having a man
just basically The Last of Us
you know for since it came out since
Friday one and just kind of a recap you
know
get my my pressure low same thing I've
been doing it and they never bad just
kind of hitting the backlog and trying
to get much stuff knocked out I think
but you know I just say that and then I
end up playing like Bioshock for the
seventh time you know and and so it's
it's basically that's been it but since
Friday last of us that's about it and
then actually play a little bit
everybody's golf kind of little break
and you know jumped on the remains and
birds loud yeah go yeah we got yeah we
got all kinds of stuff going on man you
know it is good to have you back and
good to have the hilarious jokes back on
Twitter they were missed
so we good to see the to be debuted back
out ok on these Twitter streets let's
see how it goes we're gonna see how you
know it's a trial run for sure but you
know now now Twitter's got them some
some good tools that I can use to get
rid of the food to handle exactly yo we
got we got j-dub already with the $5
suture early JD I was gonna take it but
you already busted you shot early $5
super Chad solve you want to get that
let him let people know hey shout out to
Jade over to fight Olivet at the Last of
Us 2 broke records even beat out Animal
Crossing can grounded win win it all
less talking about cells or more playing
the game I didn't do anything different
Hido
what I will tell you is who's next
we gonna get to it Jada don't worry I'll
take care of that part that portion and
I check addicts levels real quick though
you know say how you said it we keep
coming back can't do intro without attic
bed we come back if the ruler what's
going on me slow Father's Day Father's
you already dou J double average 811 you
know do you know what you remember he
know he's next
can you guys a mute aful here alright
and you already know we have the Four
Horsemen of gaming the original Lords in
a realm at the round table
Michael it's called most my brother
wouldn't know another brother from
another mother the difficult game Kagura
Lord of reviews and the half of the
young both mom men with the better Micah
know what addict are we doing sir I just
want to know how you've been saying my
name all this time for this many years
and you messed it up he said he was
partaking of us so some some liqueurs
doing gymnastics right now your your
forgiveness
we got van today he's been a good day
this week has been a good day Dale you
sound worse than me I woke up like 30
minutes ago so first off all I do want
to say the chat if you uh if you really
really really joined the last of us such
hashtag j-dub before we start that
impressions you might want to leave
because you ain't go like what I have to
so that's what's up so it's been on last
of us exclusively sir
yeah I think I've almost put 22 hours
into it oh wow you would put Network
it's a long but it's a lot of fluff but
we'll get into that save the impression
saved if residue got lapped oh and of
course we have our most technical
Gabriel Ord the solo game on is for the
single player selfish experience and
also the Sasha Adonis
a flat profile Illuminati and Lopez Sean
of the iron bake my man Lord sovereign
how we doing sir doing good what's going
on happy Father's Day to all chill a man
you know I've been doing this in honor
of the like I finished my replay of the
original like 12:15 like a Friday
morning so I have a good quick shower
it's kind of wake up and jump right back
in so that's what I've been doing oh
I've been there yeah and see what else
real quick that's all I'm bank stuff yes
all Dax my brother yes if you do not get
at me in my games I cannot give you your
code that you won last come see me yeah
what's up IOP on twitter yes I'll give
you the code for the game that you won
last week it's only also gamers play I
contacted you through patreon and again
I to content so speak to you so I can
give you a teespring way yes please
please please contact me so I can get
you guys you have won brightest
additionally to that right and I think I
completely forgot to to this with Dan
before we went live yeah we have some
things to give away am I correct - yeah
elephant right cool so uh throughout the
so what I'm gonna do for the codes that
I have already throughout the the
podcast I'll be dropping those into the
chat first one to grab it
congratulations
um those would be I guess three months
of game pass there to coach for that so
thank you this Dan and thank you to
season gaming for that so yeah my
pleasure
and additionally Lord Dan has a couple
of shirts to give away right am I am I
correct yep yeah I basically will do
however you guys want to do it I will
just get a hold me on Twitter and we'll
figure out sizes and everything and
we'll send you some shirts got one on
right now Chris I like right throughout
so the thing is so throughout the
podcast I have a couple of questions
I'll ask to the chat and the first one
to answer it correctly in full
you know I saw yes
then the winners of the king of the
experience is the leader of the fraud
what's that Jews name from Friday the
one that sorrow like that you've only
got a man to scare us create this yes
the tear that was a 72 last week is off
the table of the demon and we got this
one time with the two dollar Canadian
dollar Canadian dollar super Jack keep
your knees King we get in your chest to
non-super chaff from trucker hat hallo
stop running attic why you shave the
hair look the heads not here yet he
actually ordered it it's all route or
but we got you so up okay so yeah we got
one more two more to the night with the
five pounds each at happy Father's Day
to all on the Lord day Lord I saw some
adorable pictures reppin the crest that
was beautiful shout out because they but
the crest up man dinky Dodge was in the
building salute that y'all telling you
man you got one right there that's the
future model you should be on every baby
commercial like this is that your child
is loose a little brother what else we
got next and then we have a fight also
attack from the perfect show grand Happy
Father's Day to all the lords and to the
Xbox series ex who's about to son the PS
500 we got the legendary we got virtual
legality in the building I've got a
shadow mount manhole gloss speaking of
last of us impressions my video is going
up momentarily can't wait to hear what
you all think we know what you think
I've got to talk about that see we got a
we got a $2.00 super chat
don't act like you go you ain't got a
trucker hat it
I have to go find it struck her head I
have to go to Walmart Target I gotta
look under the aisles I don't even see
the man that was different from at all I
don't wear hats at all the other side
taking down a little bit I'll turn you
down a little bit
let me get why you doing that let me get
up my brother in separate Ghost Luke law
- awesome - cheers to my brother again
yo salute to incepting ghost man he was
on the frontlines recently doing doing a
real positives that better yeah put the
Lance Armstrong down and that Mike that
was shooted it goes man he was out there
rapping oh my god cause all the front
lamb is so Nova do not just say cooking
with truck hieratic for a patreon we
work these tears oh my god did we work
these - you know what we could do this a
certain rhythm game that just got
announced no I leave you alone this this
is for a particular Lord that is
particularly fun as you all know there's
a Kingdom Hearts yes rhythm game
' and it is a perfectly good show intro
let's go cat now if you ever seen this
Friday I was on our dog council X
channel roundtable with the team talking
statues please go and check that out
that's dcx channel Roundtable
it was beautiful man I was almost crying
I loved it so much
Kos is up go to loads of gaming dotnet
if you haven't seen it yet the new one
is up there I think that's you know one
of my best videos salute to you for
recognizing the goat Volvo failed the
Winter Soldier yeah thank you Kay I
watched it again I watched it again and
I sat there and I absorbed it right
because now you can see the whole
catalog in its entirety
and for sophomore film first of all is
the best sophomore film period right but
then I don't know who was doing the
choreography all the bruises in the
fight scene oh they was in a bag that's
the best action fight scenes and then I
said ok as a character Captain America
is hard to show his skill set right you
have to constantly have him in
particular moments and I thought that
movie eloquently showed the subtleties
and the power in which he's doing what
he's doing when he's an elevator with v
and did not use his shell to break him
down yeah I was like oh it's just so
many little things yeah and yeah so I
think the Captain American line of
movies were probably outside of the
Avenger line of movies was age of Ultron
is my favorite Avenger movie right um
but that that one I think stands
probably top - yeah shot to cut off he
made a good point we were talking about
it obviously he was saying that was good
about that moving about what your
soldier
like a Black Panthers that they're kind
of good films without heroes being
needed in them you know you don't say
and that that's the thing while since do
shot the kids smoke Happy Father's Day
to the fathers here you already know so
just know I'm gonna say Happy Father's
Day to the real daddy's the daddies that
are out here you know being that he's
being around their children working
birthday children having fun with their
children being real daddy's because I
was at a supermarket and the ladies
yelled out um well she said to the
ladies in the soup Mariana she was kind
of salty
she said yeah happy Father's Day to all
the women here oh and I and I said uh no
ma'am I'm not daddy daddy no you will
not do that trolling in the supermarket
we got Mariano Pumbaa with the five
dollars to protect we need a special
chair for all the lords Deebo be like
who did that for you either
I rarely disagree sir okay no we're
gonna we're gonna do something but this
week let me tell you man all right so um
shut up the game pass because I was
playing um was to dead Oh review uploads
of gaming dotnet as we speak shout to
raise virus go check that out
I was playing no man's sky so remember
this guy we're not gonna act like last
of us was a playable for the whole week
we had other games that we were playing
so um you know destiny and uh what else
it was another game that was inside of
game paths but my son and I are playing
last of um no man's sky together right
he's he's upstairs playing I'm
downstairs playing and he is finding
little materials and he's learning the
periodic table and how to transmute
elements and stuff like that and I'm
like I love this game
Joseph it's all of this game for the
simple fact that he's learning what's
phosphorus what
you know different things he's nine
years old that's what's up hey and he
said daddy I made a new element and I
was like what's the element so you know
we're talking about and this in this way
for us to build and bonding it about it
and then I'm playing the last of us too
and I notice a shocker to you ponies I
got your girlfriend I got your guy said
he's quickly become also bees with your
that but that's pretty much it let me
guess the Betty Smith fry cook 20 hours
super chat Salutations laws please
everyone support Lord addict reviews i
LP k OS lord gaben dotnet and the last
word and lord cog if they jack ever
while the last word is on just over the
door hit over the dough ball happy
Father's Day Yeltsin Louie bells was
going or they do it construction of my
Street it's crazy but holy nothing
honest I mention an oval balls real like
no fingers more I'll take tickle fingers
over the Nova boy you do too much of
Nova balls man someone's hold up traffic
no bomb of course we have the gaming
engine himself that shinobi lore
incognito spray never illness in the
room and ILP now tell me what you wanna
hear but what you need to hear salute to
the last word of course like my brother
speedy Smith said we had on Jarvan s the
legend from the UK man great show got a
chance to break some stuff down and talk
balancing and everything that's going on
it tends to play much but a bad sleep
week I'll try to start Last of Us two
separate occasions but I got this little
I think what it is damn when you get oh
I can't play a game when I'm tired like
I don't know yeah yeah in the old days
it didn't matter I just be excited like
part of me is like you I got a respect
this game and be at my best cuz I want
to blaze so I try to Adam hit me up like
he saw me late last night working on a
show he said yo what's up just thought I
might listen man I know me if I start
I'm gonna want to keep going and I can't
be doing a head nod well bottom layer
I will be doing it I got some different
format for the last was stuff going on
today but enough about that now solve do
you want to get into what you want to do
a shot you jump into my floor how you
would how you boys will come to your
flow what I'm gonna do is so whenever
Dan is ready Dan how many are you giving
away today publisher certs - okay cool I
have two questions on we can do that
throughout the show and then again the
coach for the three months of game packs
is I will just drop them into the chat
randomly nice oh my lord wait wait heck
in a chat that is one of the best one of
our best and Lords of gaming dine and
salute to him we already know Rob from
the Middle East very happy Father's Day
brother happy Father's Day to you it
goes you know saying to the little was
but we got to get into this show there's
a lot going on right now and um before
we do that we got to start with all know
it did you know his video game system
history his passion for gaming and of
course what led him to the seasoned
gaming and the amazing big cast so Lord
did let's start from the very beginning
man what was some of the first video
games as if you had and what got you to
gaming no it's funny like last night I
was uh we kind of went our little drive
me in the wife and we uh I was like man
I gotta work on my gaming history
together cuz you know what I say a lot
is you know if I'd slept I forgot it was
hella boring 1975 oh geez oh shout out
shout out yes and I was uh so we started
my dad you know beating father's days
kind of cool um he was really kind of
the catalyst for my gaming you know we
should man yeah we should it was it was
and so we all kind of tried to pass that
on to the kids to responsibly obviously
but um we started with 2600 oh that's
you know yours revenge all that stuff
was a revenge oh thank you yeah yeah man
we had the peddled we had everything it
was nice and then we kind of went from
there to Coleco my language
yes thanks no backhand you guys remember
of it you know this is gonna sound a
little bit old but you know you you can
go to bowling alleys nowadays and
there's like a little arcade he had an
arcade that had a bowling alley it was
so big I approached a cargo originally
so uh yeah they uh they had this it's
called galaxies world mm-hmm and we used
to go there my dad used to stop at the
gas station grab a pack of smokes and
then sit there at a sit down Gallagher
machines and two ashtrays full of tokens
and we just kind of go back and forth me
and my brothers doing and we grabs and
you know all day you know am I is
awesome it was fine yeah Star Wars that
arcade me here head yep galloping is his
that was hit man he was he would just
sit there played Galaga first so you
know an hour's well we yeah and that was
that was a good time and that was really
why did a lot of my gaming cuz it wasn't
too far from her house though but after
Coleco I really didn't have anything
else we kind of work from there to
Nintendo okay and just straight into you
know like Bionic Commando obviously
Mario Metroid has no gold no 13
I remember loaded pixels that was his
game he could not stop talking that and
it was all my cinematics like kind of
big for his time right that's a classy
rocket in you did right see and I got I
got in the chat already getting mad at
all don't let him start with that go go
down easily voted the legend is gonna to
build this he's a gaming reppin you
already don't go go 34 I'll keep it all
I keep it calling from there we I mean
we basically stuck with like we would
get consoles like we got a Super NES and
then we would kind of jump back and
forth like my brother would get one I
would get when we just swap back and
forth
Super NES n64 yeah this is the one I got
and and you know that was no fantasy
star to to examine our old you know you
know watches let's go Ralph death
I forgot mmm and then let's see I got
the CD with it which I don't know if
that was a really smart purchase but you
know I don't know a single game from
that Sonic game and some other stuff and
then the 32x I had the whole system old
boat Ron let's go and was arcade on that
game or on the 32x remember - I was i
played too much of that and then I I
went to college in 94 before I graduated
it's what he'll make up on the place we
came out oh I had pre-ordered it got the
PlayStation Oh better she didn't yes
those are all the games Amy Parasite Eve
was I may be remiss that Sam theme yeah
man I'm waiting for that one good oh
yeah Ben you know you kind of get you
know to the point where I can't hit a
roll made me want some PS PlayStation 2
ps2 you know but that was when GTA 3
came out I was big into that middle
first game oh yeah Maxim goal shout-out
to Maximo Baskerville yes let's go and
then go from there that was the venn
Xbox dues to Xbox I just I think I
thought in like magazines you know go
figure you know way before you know it
was that big so gosh I'm old oh jeez oh
let's go yeah I got the OG xbox I was I
was never there was a thing though I
like if you had to categorize me in I'm
more probably an Xbox guy but I'm never
and really into the Xbox exclusives
which is super weird you know that was
more you know it was just the new thing
to have right so we'll like whenever the
New Deal so you kind of like us in a
sense that you got to see what the next
level is kind of on console yes exactly
yep one from there had kotor was my big
one on that original Xbox that was my
favorite game class I still had that's I
don't have any physical copies of any
games except for kotor and kotor 2 and
they're still sitting downstairs
so yeah man it's it's those are my
all-time favorites then 360 one two
three of those to the rumor about that
$60 talked about that was that was more
like assassin's creed red dead 3 you
know we're in the redemption I'm sorry
you know you afro sava friends for life
in El Khatib you know I mean everybody
my friends played halo I played a little
bit of it here and there hold on angels
on you and he said do not let hit a
disrespect halo he's all yeah he's
waiting for slamming private chat you
know you need to go in here and air on a
dirty lon shout out to the overseer
watching that legally to Dan no way
represents to your peers and CEO he put
the disclaimer early the only counselor
really didn't had was a ps3 and with
pretty expensive and that at that time
you know is just really get a second job
but I though oh you know and I missed
out on some games you know but I also
wasn't into like you know I just wanted
to play games you know that's it that's
always comes down to you know so that
one from there the Xbox one obviously
switch to pretty much digital once they
started you know going on
on that route you got to a terabyte
brick hard drive sitting there connected
to my old one so yeah that's that's
where I do most of my gaming now is on
the Xbox one and I really didn't get a
ps4 two kind of later in the cycle down
the gin yeah so the game it made you say
okay now it's time a happy sea so it was
it was kind of a tie between NLB the
show and you guys are like oh tag-team
it looks like I cannot buy the system
for a baseball game
but they got the best Bezos it was not
even close if you wait a one more year
like next year we have that Oh shouted a
field ominous Maximus presumably oh
really - oh what was the other game
horizon zero dawn I really wanted to
play that snoring pings oh what no
horizon zero dawn was one of them that I
really wanted to get to do so but that
was it turned out to be one of my
favorite games on the ps4 that's his
favorite air salute it was really you
know I've got thousand games on xbox you
know and that's where most of my library
is I've got maybe a couple hundred on
the ps4 now so it's it's more you know
then it was God of War and spider-man
and all that other stuff you know and I
got to play The Last of Us which I never
played before I'd never played any of
the Uncharted games so you know I was
able to go back to play I played one in
four which is weird
and played part or two but it's pretty
dated so it's kind of tough yeah
everybody tells me - is the best but I
mean no now in cyberpunk now especially
so you've got job we go go
you've never got to oh let me get DCHS
real quickshot the lord museu de builded
lord's favorite magazine and go mine was
tips and trips it for me Disney was
electronic gaming monthly EGF was my
mom's next generation X Gen and game fan
yeah because next gen um they material
they like the bags fire shout the one
away dragon TV final a super chat happy
Father's Day to the panel and everyone
in the chat
gogo 13 was the hardest game ever
jumping tank levels facts hey Louis kid
Cedric H with no points happy Father's
Day Lord still met okay perform of
course but I don't need account game
informal near mill cuz every time you go
to gamestop they give it to you
basically when you wanted something we
don't count the free stuff do they put
the game Rhodey 1000x yo-yo without
those classic magazines yes five dollars
from regulator happy Father's Day to all
the gaming dads the struggle is real the
game and father at the same time love
the podcast King David colectomy yes sir
I'll be doing God's work Eli so pretty
much down I just have one system I have
to ask you about in here of two actually
two one the turbo graphics 16 and ok and
the Dreamcast did you a dream I did have
to drink ass okay yeah
that was that was NFL 2k man that was
yes a game you played kasia was a what
the head with the ready to rumble that
oh yes that one was really good it was
that game that system i think it's a
shame that it didn't you know keep going
i think you know when when all that news
broke about sega possibly coming out
with another console or something you
know you know whatever the rumors were
whatever the micro is i don't want to
talk about it you know I was I was
pretty stoked about it you know I had to
come back down you know I know
you guys are like the Sega Nintendo
mm-hmm I was right in the middle man I'm
right there so it was it was the genesis
one of my all-time faves facts that was
that was amazing
but you know also you know you've got a
lot of fond memories and that's really
what gaming's about for me but as far as
like meeting the guys on yes Amy so
literally jumped into my next question I
would say so how did that whole thing
happen like how did you guys link like I
had a Twitter account that I basically
used for like news and information back
way back in the day and I won a fallout
4 limited edition Xbox they made like
500 of them okay let's say was Adam
Kovac from like rooster yeah I won I won
something from mini sayin I got it I was
like this is the coolest thing ever and
I actually was like well you know I've
got the or the new version but s was
coming out I was like you know what I'm
gonna get the new version and so I put
it up on eBay well I met the guy who
bought it with Xbox out at the fan fest
yes nice guy and I am through there and
through him he kind of introduced me to
gaming Twitter which is you know I
didn't realize you know that was nuts so
you know I you know and I've names there
and I just kind of looked at his profile
one time and it said you know he's in
Kansas City I'll turn up he was actually
from Olathe Kansas which is where I'm
from we just say Kansas City because
nobody knows we're like this you know
Schaumburg in Chicago you say you from
Chicago where people have yeah
you know and so we he was like 10
minutes away from me which is crazy he
said we had AIDS
craziness so now you know we kind of got
together when I had a couple you know
beers played some arcade games at a
thing called traffic aid don't yep and
then him and Burt asked me to come on
and shout out the bird yeah it was
awesome and that was that was it and the
rest is history I kind of had a couple
other you know podcasts that I you know
getting into the pot game it was also
kind of a mad thing because when he
passed away somebody had asked me to
come on one of their shows and yeah I
just kind of started getting into it
after that um so it was I don't mean to
bring the mood down yeah and in through
that I kind of get into the podcasting
part we had a peanut buddy oh and had a
short-lived third wheel arcade it was
called it was just nonsense like a lot
of it was super fun though man I mean
it's I do miss that show doing that with
him yeah
we had like a third wheel was always me
and him in a third guy yeah you always
bringing somebody else and we had so
much fun doing that stuff because it was
just you know calling out the crazies oh
yeah yeah it was it was a good time but
you know seeing is also you know it's
really really good it's yeah when I
there's you know no ads on the site it's
all about purity brother that's it
you know and so much you know I I can't
run really lucky to admit him and to be
asked to come on the show and actually
contribute to yeah like first thing
really respect what you guys do because
from a journalistic standpoint it's pure
integrity it's no fluff it's no BS
there's no ad room it's literally about
the game so the movement is pure that's
number one so we got to celebrate that -
you know me as far as year the big cast
we got a chance obviously to listen to
you guys I got a chance to be on it as a
world which was awesome
oh shout today oh yeah guys do me I was
amazing I'm still one of the best yeah
it may be like a tag team kidding play
salute and then we gotta solve it we all
got a chance we got to be a bird
you know saying on the rooftops my
little Bert oh yes like you know just a
great group of guys that represent the
right thing and you guys are beloved in
the community man so I just what they
got the roses while you can smell them
you know they talk what are the good
guys that destice that are still left do
it and you back you're hilarious you
know I've seen a couple early reviews I
love what you bring guys yeah we play
the game and I'm not I'm not a big fan
of anything at this point in my life
i'ma play games probably an easy mode as
well I love those games just watch them
mhm and I tried to play them I suck
I'm just not the SEC you know like like
Jedi fallen order was like you know
pushing it for me no reaction then goes
fast
I call it I call it your BS meter we
could play Mega Man and die a million
times on a level trying to make that
jump
all right
fine now if we were to play Mega Man I
don't even play Mega Man I leave that
level right there won't come back
thinking no idea Dark Souls come on bro
we do it stuff with you had to keep the
system own and go to one city I say this
right I say to any of you little
whippersnappers a little wet behind the
ears I say this I say go play magician
Lord or neo when you can end that game
then you shout out you shout out to me
do that because I did that game
literally if you I couldn't break my
control those are controllers that you
could not toss because those controllers
cost 150 bucks back then which would
probably be like $300 now so if you will
gently place it down and go kick a wall
or something
yeah stitch to them with the faruk akat
king who got that last of us PVC steps
mouki user reviews compared to the
critics quote-unquote in the book of let
me give you a little background at that
really quickly
somebody called me broke so for you I
give you this and then he hit me with
the you don't know who I am
I'm like no I decide to sit for the
background watch it like okay I like
collecting me stuff you about the boxing
me about the boxing me if innocent if it
fits it ships
we gotta move over there we got a lot of
stuff to get into but I got to ask Lord
at the round table
video games of all time alright so which
one was the best
oh shut up to the Ducks to bring down
action
Lucas come Casa de Ville do superjet did
you talk about last of us to yet
what's up fellas Happy Father's Day to
all the kids we bout to get to him gonna
smash the tabata baby's gotta finish it
with dad and then you want to get
regulator damn please don't say bucks oh
good so we got Bioshock we got Mass
Effect all right yep um last of us I
think was probably one of my favorite
games it's probably more recent one just
the first one yes just because of I
don't know it's kind of a combination of
just the storytelling and the you know
the the way the emotional connection
that you can make to the characters
which you don't see a lot in games you
look at you got some of that with like
red there too
able to put yourself kind of in those
Jews and you know that and that's kind
of one of those honorary meant to be
like there's so many games I play I
mentioned parasite eve under that one
forever
okay well such a good game and then I'm
gonna go with The Witcher 3
I played the second one through the
tutorial and I said the hell with this
game this is terrible and then when my
buddies said hey you need to try The
Witcher 3 I said man I tried The Witcher
2 if it's anything like that I don't
anything new ility terrible and then so
finally he convinced me was like 10
bucks or something that's like this game
is really really good to you baby yeah
shout out to card wire with the two
pounds to protect turrican 2 for all 5
speaking of which I don't know if that
the deal is still on but if you um I
believe if you link any any account that
you owned with your three-on-two GOG
galaxy or something like that
you get a free PC copy if you don't have
that right yes so Lulu in the last
question I got for Lord Dan favorite
console of all time generations just one
I'm gonna go with Coleco only because it
means there's such a like a special
connection with my dad and myself on
that I'm that console there's a whole
venture fake sure yeah but you do dilute
a face with the little arrow it'll mean
was tell me that green monster scare the
hell out you put yeah yes it did we
played that game that was the one and
for that reason you know probably I bet
I'm gonna stick with the ColecoVision
um obviously there's you know more
advanced talk about that when you want
it I'm giving you all into something
let's go keep talking buddy go talk
that's the one with that one in zaxxon
you know the games that we connected
with and that I will you know always
kind of hold a special place in bro we
share this you definitely want to sell
on my dad got me in a game in Cali
was my first system and I think I want
our clicker doesn't get enough credit is
that if you really look at it there is
only console to kind of give Sega and
Nintendo Adventure
yeah member vegi no not Adventure Govind
oh he got it
I've got that's it that's great this
this is the greatest machine I have
69,000 game I was running around with
66,000 I know it's 69 thousand memories
for you and your dad man there's benches
a class why would this things like
Coleco was so unique for his time
because it had if you really look at it
all it guys that ended up becoming big
game players like Sega and Nintendo they
kind of debut a lot of their games on
Coleco Donkey Kong got a pack in you
know I'm saying it was a tremendous
systemically coronation you've already
run oh great game in history so we gonna
get into the poll and the rest of the
show
so last week poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the recent announcement of PlayStation 5
digital edition console how do you think
Sony should position its configuration
in preparation for the Lockhart the
winner of our and it's a super close
three-way ILP poll at 38% of the vote
was the digital edition should ship as
the same price as PlayStation 5 but with
a much larger SSD group too bad that
ain't happening cuz we got good for her
no yeah but that it did happen it is the
same coming in at a razor close 36
percent so first was 38 seconds 36 was
the digital edition should be a hundred
hours cheaper than the places your
father take the hardware loss to
undercut Lockhart and in last place at
25 strong 25 though was I don't care
because I'm getting confused by two
skills at launch participated Lord
Saab what do you think about this
yeah they - needs to be a hundred
dollars less which I think it will be I
mean
that is that is their way of trying to
you know jump into the market and not
and hit you in the head with that price
they don't want to hit you in the head
with mm-hmm but and actually by
purposely making the disk console look
considerably uglier than the other one I
think that personally still gonna be
taking it out on the diskless version
what it's it's a lot less of an l a-- i
think they willing to eat that yeah
which is you know that's why I think la
carte is coming in at $200 straight up
Wow Wow okay no matter what they do they
go but let me see if we got it yeah okay
yeah one super say yeah we have element
appeal with the final so exactly happy
day lords happy Father's Day to all your
families own your opinions community
thank you nurse salut salut
you all ready we caught up we all caught
up yeah we definitely know that we gonna
get in see these topics you already know
Lord Agassi him you don't know if he's
back this is top of it if not I could
set it off in Pizza Pizza time so I look
and say who got a pizza we got a lot of
last of us to talk about you know saying
a precious review this is Lord addicts
topic okay go get it go down so we go do
things a little different before we get
into that but we got to actually get to
some breaking news or last it was - in a
shout-out to Lord Benji sales so he says
buckle up we've got our first
record-breaking moment so the last was
two biggest Sony opening ever in the UK
biggest launch of 2020 by far in the UK
passing animal crossing this and this is
physical sales only not digital
so that's crazy and he said we've got a
monster world while opening up he said
it seems clear last was to is going to
outsell spider-man in Europe the
previous only record holder Sony did a
Spidey to three point three million in
three days globally he says he wonder is
the
of us can hit 4 million in 3 days and
the last thing he said you'll keep in
mind that dis launched bigger than
Uncharted 4 in physical copies alone
he said Digital has grown greatly since
then this could be a colossal launch so
that is just now today busy sales with
what's going on obviously we've got a
lot to talk about in reference to the
game it is out we got to get our
pressure so I want to start it off first
with on the positive what for those who
have played I know adding up waiting
from to come back you know and I solved
but what what are we thinking about the
game so far from what we have played
masala we don't know damn alright yeah I
think it's a gorgeous game I have
enjoyed my time coming back to a you
know familiar characters it's always
great and the mechanics are super
familiar but you know they're improved
but you know I think so they've done a
really good job with that there is I
mean it's it's I'm only maybe 12 13
hours into it but I'm kind of like you
guys I'm checking every corner every
trash can every you know everything you
know I'm crawling through it so it yeah
I can't speak on the story cuz you know
you kind of don't know where it's going
yet you know I don't anyway so but so
far man I'm really enjoying my time with
it for sure is it hitting me as hard as
the last of us did not yet but you know
who knows no idea no doubt but so far
you would say like I said just the
gameplay mechanics um graphically those
are things standing out to you the most
what's standing out the more that's like
wow you're really impressed with I would
say probably the just the graphics you
know some of the cutscenes are just like
you know gorgeous even just some of the
the small interactions that you have
with the world they did a really cool
job with it's just these little things
and a lot of these little things add up
to you know more of a you know the
bigger picture but like I said it's it's
so it's hard to talk about without you
know giving anything away I just I know
it's you know that well I can focus on
right now yeah I'm bad you know the
mechanics the only thing without
spoiling anything is the the crafting
system
I love how they kind of did that like
the upgrading of your weapons and you
know little yeah it's a little kind of
you know and quality lot of improvement
but it's actually you know it's really
cool they sit down
you know what saw how busy I was have
you got it no what have you been feeling
positive things what you've been
enjoying about laugh force first off big
shout out congratulations to Evo xxx Evo
for winning that our first co so thank
you too Lord Dan and season gaming for
that salute yeah so I love the Last of
Us I love that game and I'm about 15
hours in but again like like Danny I
sort of look at every little corner
looking cranny and all the time you
don't find anything but I just like to
listen okay these guys spent years upon
years making this game I'm gonna take
the time to see to see it to you know
fully I'm gonna see every environment
and take pictures all over the place I
got the photo mode haha so um so what
can I say in terms of obviously graphics
the game is a beautiful game it makes
you know you see people talking about
the the level of violence and we're not
in the game and things like that and I
think it just makes the the advancement
of the graphics and the engine sort of
brings all of that stuff to life like
when you when you kill someone from
behind and in little you can hear them
gurgling and choke and you see them
choking on their own blood it's like
somebody had to sit and animate this
expressions to when I start having
insane
it really is insane so uh no kudos to
them for the amount of time and effort
they put into that so I want to make
sure that I actually see all of that um
in terms of the gameplay that things
that they changed their quality of life
stuff the combat the fact that they give
you a Dodge button now sort of about a
little bit more like it's it's still not
you don't like it's not a fighting that
fun game comment but it just it makes
everything feel a little more realistic
and it shows you that these people have
our seasoned fighters that they've been
fighting these infected for a long time
yeah and so it just it adds that little
extra layer to the combat that's cool
mom the addition of going prone is
meaningless
somebody who loves stealth games like
calculus that we stealthy they turned it
into Splinter Cell for me like million
is crazy
so that that I really love about the
game um one thing that Dan mentioned
that I sort of don't like in how the the
upgrades good work now is it before in
the first game you could pretty much
choose which upgrades you go with first
depending on your place down here it's
like a tree so it's a skill tree that
you have to open up certain upgrades in
a certain order that they they sort of
determined for you and then you're able
to upgrade but until you open up that
that upgrade in the tree and access it
whereas in the first one they were all
available and you just had to have
enough and enough sort of uh whatever
points or whatever to open that up and
you decide how you wanted to play the
game but it was different than that I
didn't like that too much
okay um so what I play it's obviously
I'm not gonna talk about story or
anything like that in spoiler Edition
what I've played so far the game this
this is what I feel mmm remember just
positive first Oh cuz we go go in but I
was okay yes don't go yeah I want this
isn't it okay yeah so this is missus is
not necessarily positive it's not really
a negative so I'll just leave that for
the next section no Prabhas I got
questions I'm gonna go to King by C
Atticus back attic are you back sir yeah
yeah as a waiting on you brother you
know where's doors so let me let's get
to you man we and you've been talking a
while about this um again we're gonna
just all the positives what are you
impressed about would last time us to
could you told me some stuff that had me
blown away I'm impressed pretty much the
whole game with the story like graphics
look amazing
the gameplay you could tell that they
definitely took the criticism that they
got from last one they're like oh you
didn't like that is gone oh you didn't
like that that's gone like they took a
lot of aspects from other games like
like you know like he says one or so and
they they've improved on that formula oh
yeah a regular or
why I wanted to ask um you know like
certain little questions about it um
that's all because I'm playing on the
pros I wouldn't I know the experience
uh-huh on a regular so that's why I was
asking I just say man that said he
didn't want the series extra took an
advantage of he he wanted the same
experience off all them when I bring
that up I get a tag everything I play it
was just a question I'm in the middle of
a conversation and you buddy what you
playing it on because I wanted to know
like I just Katie at it continued
brother we with you Anakin
nothing we got the old you talk about
alright the good things now let me
actually city law straight though one
thing you told me that thought was cool
was on something about like the enemies
that you kill and like them saying
something about the names and and yeah
like you know obviously you know in
other games you come across a group of
AI it's just pretty much like they have
no personality they're literally just
fodder doing you in the next checkpoint
right what I really liked the attention
to detail that Naughty Dog put into this
game is they all have different names
and you know some of the times he can
get a little you know I saw Jason Shire
put on Twitter that you know he said
some name I think it was Jason or
something like that he's like well the
third person I don't think I've ever
heard the same name but you know I don't
really pay attention to that degree yeah
but what I do like is like you kill
someone they're like and then when when
the other NPCs roll on it they're like
you know someone killed bins
you know and then when another thing
that I really notice is when you kill
someone in front of someone else they
react to it
you know you tell huh
yeah they're like like and and they
they're they get more aggressive it's
like they're generally upset that you
killed a homie and you know what I like
is you know obviously there's dogs in
Last of Us - that's one of the new
enemies that they put in the game I
don't know how the dogs over there on
the pro look like but they is not even
that my question was the stability of
framerate and stuff like that though the
questions that I was going I think it's
definitely a lock 3000 but you know what
I what I really like about the doctors I
was on a roof and I I was I was creeping
around trying to you know Scout how many
peoples are on where they're around and
I have a rule if I see a dog he's dead I
see a dog he's the first one going when
you kill a dog so what it is is again
I'm talking from no experience I refuse
to play this game tired I'm gonna start
my play session tonight but my question
is is it a situation that you gotta
target them first because they [ __ ]
they have they can get your scent
oh that bothers me it's not the same
it's the aggressiveness that they are
they on you they have an animation where
if they get close enough close to you
they will jump on you and you will fall
on your back and then you know that's
not the place to be on in Last of Us do
something like you know so I'm sitting
here but with the cool thing is you know
they implied that dodge mechanic so you
could dodge them if they launched at you
but if they catch you you're probably
dead so you know what I notice is you
know I see a dog and you know I like
killing the dogs at the boat cuz it's a
watch
I'm sitting there across the back shot
him he went down and I'm expecting the
next dude to look around for me you know
it was like I just killed the person
because he had him on a leash right and
I'm sitting I'm okay I expect this the
the the the chick that had him picks up
the dog and holds it starts crying Wow
and then after that like she started
running at me like she didn't care about
where she was all she like she lost it
like she literally blasted was given us
artificial intelligence like it really
felt like that you know I killed this
dog that she's raised since it was a pup
and she lost her she lost her mind
which obviously she was easy to kill it
that combat that I forgot to mention is
I shot this lady once right and she
started wailing like Craig ah screaming
like in a way I hadn't heard another
alright why did she start wailing and
screaming like that when I closer to her
to a body I shot her hand off oh realize
I had shot her her hand was next to the
body I'm like oh so a toast oh it's kind
of too far to see what it how it
transpired but it got out of hand all
but she was like staring at the stump
like screaming hey yeah and you know
what else is crazy is like the
repercussions things are like gun combat
it's like real life like you know you
can't just run at someone and get shot a
couple times and act like it you just
took that like you know if I see someone
and I get like they've got these big
sledgehammers I love them and I have one
and there's this this person coming at
me I'm I'm gonna get you it's close
enough where I think I can get that that
sledgehammer to his noggin before he
shoots me yeah didn't happen that way
Wow like this he shot me and ha le gonna
act like she didn't even in that motion
oh no you can't do that like you can die
very easily because there's such a
reaction to getting shot and you
literally stopped moving you stopped
running
and not to mention if you get shot with
an arrow you fall on the ground
yeah attic where you ran at someone and
then I immediately jump into prone so
they're shooting at me I dive into prone
shoot at their legs drop their legs get
back up and run on it run at them and
then hit them with my melee weapon you
could do that sort of stuff in a way
that you could in the first game but I
it just makes it the way it feels in
this book it was shown like that in the
trailer leading up to the game that we
thought that it wasn't going to do that
we thought we did not know about the
door and so you know what what I really
I just enjoyed the attention to detail
you know that's one of the reasons it's
you know as of right now it's an 8 out
of 10 for me and the story I had to take
too because I had to get him off the
phone the other day he was just talking
about talking about a character in the
game start talking or anything but we'll
be a solve one of them drops I shot is
from Call of Duty shoot big legs what I
really really enjoy about this cuz I'm a
huge stealth person I love
I've killed I played all the dishonor of
that killing one person I've played all
of the the Ducks revolution without
killing anyone I've you know I played
all I played all the Splinter cells but
the best one arguably the blacklist
mm-hmm and I love stealth no but last of
us was stealth but it wasn't stealth it
was like kind of a mid grain you can
play this whole game still you don't so
I've went to host section be like yeah
you've none of you saw me I just want to
write I all of you saw and what I like
is you can lay in tall grass you can go
prone in tall grass what do they come up
on you then grab them and snap they neck
like no no let's get a kid game at King
fondo you ever got a chance to long but
you did play even more than me I don't
even turn it on yet so where you at with
what are you liking about it so for
shout out the Sony be in the words
download no I guess I just want to say
that's more of my frustration and that's
where a couple of my hours went because
there are a lot of time we can do what's
the break it apparently
Crash Bandicoot 4 was just announced if
you if you want to see more on it
apparently they're gonna reveal it on
June the 22nd but shout out to undead
Lords gave me that net we weren't we
were on that so even like reading the
guy when I'm looking for some good good
good you go for a besides the download
speed which so ok so besides the the
incredibly disgusting download when I
did get a chance to actually play the
game you know so I booted it up and
first it started off in my head I'm like
yeah cuz just the recap of the story you
know hit me again
and I was like yeah I did realize that
they didn't need a part two let's let's
yeah let's let's get to it and right
since we here let's get to it right all
right um so I'm playing a game and I'm
seeing the direction that it's going in
and you know it starts off as a movie so
you just sit down have your popcorn
ready to just you know just oh now it's
my time to move okay
beautiful right so now when I'm getting
to the the aspect of the movements right
right and they teach they taking you
through a little tutorial how they doing
like we're introducing you to the game
and showing you the new stuff the dodge
buttons beautiful
the prone stuff is fantastic what I
truly love is the holding your breath
and the world turns to monochrome and
you see that enemy's highlighted in
white like behind boys and it gives you
such a daredevil sixth sense and the
world slows down and I found that to be
so incredible right and ice and I said
okay they needed this mechanic because I
know the AI is definitely going to be on
some super level now I'm like three to
four hours into the game because I'm
like sovereign and everybody else I'm
one of those people and you know King
you know how I knew that that AI was
gonna be on point when they gave you the
off she was like yo he can't flank you
yo he can't do this I didn't delve into
that I just put my joint on easy and
whatever I didn't go into shutting
people legs off or like you like there's
so many options that you can make the AI
dumb with like pretty much like I said
on the very lows how they were like we
were talking about that on what who was
that on numbers on what them will yeah
he's talking about the fact that there
you can camp the game but still get the
trophies a little kind of stupid you
know should come with the asterisk like
Barry Bonds oh there's not a trophy for
beating the games so while I'm playing
the game right okay I didn't like one
season I was like I said okay alright
but then something happened and then you
know season change right and I said Wow
mm-hmm okay this is the price of a
mission now I'm saying a PlayStation 4
now I'm seeing the pro work and I'm
saying okay because my machine
definitely says I did turn up the you
know the bowl that boat was you gotta go
boy this is a big boy so I'm like yeah
he's working PlayStation is working
graphics is looking incredible I love
that you come bus into cars I bust the
windows into
like if you don't see a way in to
certain things just use common sense and
you can do real-life physical things to
stuff I like how like ropes have out of
the castle yeah it's amazing in the
level of detail and the thought process
that they did to put into it right so
I'm playing it and then it's a moment
where the musicality hits you right
because the last of us the first one it
was some musicality into it and it tied
me to the game that made me finish it
right right and now he you know Joel
have made a promise and now the promise
was realized and then the musicality
comes in because it links me to the game
and I'm seeing how to use him a shout
out to Naughty Dog for using that damn
controller okay
shoutout to them for using a swipe up
that the molest button in the front
shout out to them for using you know the
the reaction center on your controller
shout out to them using the system to
the fullest capability and I appreciate
it and thank you so much so you know
when you're doing the music thing is a
palace like well I've got a little Tim I
because you felt the emotion of this
scene mm-hmm and if you don't respect
anything from this game you must respect
the writing because to put the scene
together like a lot of scenes start off
with something mundane is how writing on
a piece of paper mm-hmm
with a pen but the animation and the
thought that went into the scene is so
top-notch its movie quality stuff here
so from the foil foliage to the growing
prone to the daredevil type senses it
encapsulates what I think that the
PlayStation mantra is like you know for
these news that play playstation it's a
single-player game right that isolates
you it sucks you into the world and I
think that's exactly what all
PlayStation people truly love game
that's exactly what's missing off of
Xbox so I can definitely see that
feeling and is a tangible feeling that
you get when a game is done right and
they definitely on to something so
that's why I'm at with it let me get to
my negative that's impressive for King
I'm proud of King right no this is it
this might be because I thought last of
us the first one was the greatest
PlayStation 3 game yes so I think this
might be the greatest PlayStation 4 game
I think got a war still better than that
that's a hell with that let's fight oh
man smash that Oh Lord here we go so
let's get it to the smoke obviously
there'd been a lot of comments social
media I don't know if say if it's like
polarizing but the people have very
strong opinions on this game so I just
wanted to bring some stuff to y'all
attentions like so I mean if you don't
put some negatives to put some negatives
to put the negative I do appreciate you
to the one that said it was broke so
listen man you know obviously some
controversy regarding the game but I
want to read some stuff to you guys
obviously guys have played it and um and
I want your guy's opinion or the
roundtable of these comments so the
first is kind of what ticking alluded to
which was like hey you know it doesn't
necessarily need a sequel some people
felt part one had the perfect ending I
think saw have you've alluded to this
before in the past you know that saw
part one had last what had a promise to
perfect anything so this is what people
are saying and I'm gonna read about
these three points one character choices
and plot holes were so bad throughout
the game that at times they would laugh
at Lau and this is shot off they're also
just a skill up as well so let's go um
he said also the game is twenty five
hours long one section feels like a 10
hour side quest he said he would not
have finished it it had he not being
reviewing and then he said even though
there are improvements to car graphics
combat and exploration attic he's saying
the enemy AI is still very bad last
point and I see this one a lot they said
the story is relentlessly bleak there
are no like
characters and no comic relief
everything you liked about the
characters in the first game is gone so
you know this is pretty much I've been
seeing a lot of this I'm gonna shout out
to hold the law you know we've had our
whole gonna show many times you know I'm
saying he's very opinionated and um you
know this is what he had to say he was
like he just ended it you know he said
it's the prettiest game about virtually
nothing that has ever made he said had a
good time with it but Natalie the story
is ludicrous the character motivations
bipolar and the pacing atrocious he said
so he would do a post-mortem a spoiler
when I can't watch that into that but
look I'm gonna bring it to y'all start
off with a dick I know you have strong
things to say what are you are you
agreeing with these points and what are
you feeling on oughta cons if there are
any cons that you know what I agree with
those but I do think some of them are
blown out of proportion I think that
some people are getting too emotional
with their their connection to the first
one right and not letting the sequel
like be a sequel of like sometimes
things aren't happy sometimes things
happen like you know and I feel like
people get so attached to these worlds
that if it doesn't work the way they
wanted to in their head and they think
it's a bad stole or one second cuz we
got the legend BG in a building broken
games HD or 10 hours of chat sup Lords
the last most part to gameplay and story
is great story is way better than last
of us one because it shows multiple
perspectives and angles that make sense
and are practical in the brutal world
that last of us is in what do you say
that adding and that's that's B's that's
his opinion you two entirely different
people and I respect VG's opinion as a
content creator and I don't I don't have
an issue with that he says but to me I
feel like there are some some hiccups in
the story not in a and other people
that's griping on this and me it's two
different tuning riping on it because of
certain scenarios they did I'm griping
on it for completely it
like a nobody but whatever digital all
digital $2 of attack no happy Father's
Day and we have somebody for him no
beginner is BG Oh baby I call myself
yeah I don't know why my car not shown
okay that's so you kids pulled up right
quick we go get yeah that's what adding
to finish his joy so at what what else
are you not feeling because you felt
strongly about some things everything
I'm not feeling I can't say so okay
without tears into the game without
spoiling is it heritage miss is it is it
what definitely no it's it's not your
you know the every what everyone else is
complaining but I just think certain
things don't make sense to the overall
yeah we talked her better off if he says
that then he's going to break what we're
trying not trying no and that's fine but
I get you guys can't generalize because
again no no no I was talking about I get
real like tangible I get it but my thing
is from what I'm hearing a lot of people
have issues with character motivations a
lot some people are saying they do not
agree with and good I disagree with that
I think the motivations are there it's
just the execution of why the
motivations are there is the problem
gachi all right let's get BGA right clay
that we get there BG and feel very
strongly about it I sort of tweet up in
there
you know where are you at with the
detractors BG's inability left he's gone
he said Oh fixed fixed his camera as I
call but you've lost his voice
mud thing just like flipped out okay
there you go yeah you got you got so my
question is obviously you see a lot of
some of the negative that's going on
with the game like what are you feeling
are they are no spoilers pls no spoilers
which is well well I think the story is
great look like I don't like I think
it's people I think it's simply people
that are in love with I guess a
narrative or I think I think and gamers
are conditioned to certain things
happening and video games because let's
let's be real you know and in most games
the same thing happens
the end right like even if we don't play
the game 99% of games even 99% of movies
we know what's gonna happen in the end
you get the happy ending exactly you get
the happy ending there's not there's
there's rarely ever a movie there's
really ever a game where there's not
necessarily like at least on the middle
in the Union nineteen you didn't get
that easily this is very jarring for
people who are attached to characters in
my opinion yeah that like what you don't
give them that which pushes what they
were expecting they hate it it makes me
feel bad it makes them feeling come this
is a very uncomfortable game it's very
uncomfortable for people to to watch and
that's why I feel they hate it they
would they want to feel good they want
to feel like the typical you know linear
good guy first bad vet bad guy type of
thing and this game does not give you
that there's no good guys and bad guys
gotcha yeah you nailed it for someone
I've played yeah I'm like very intrigued
let me get daddy a bit then I mean from
the criticisms that you seen you know
and from what you have played so far you
know do you think any of it is justified
I think anybody can have whatever
opinion they want to I mean that's the
thing about it is you know until you
finish the game and you've played all
the way through it I mean it's as far as
story goes and you know knowing what
happens right you know it Meredith you
know before you criticize that and to be
fair there there has been some times
where it's kind of like it's kind of
been all over the place it's kind of
like what doing here you know there's
definitely been those moments it's not
you know you said something about pacing
that's probably pretty true yeah there's
some pacing issues for sure I can't
speak on the overall narrative because I
finished but I yeah I mean everybody you
know just just as long as you play the
game you know what I mean I'm kind of
does is if don't don't just make up your
opinion based on what you've seen right
you know you gotta have hands on yeah I
don't I don't go you know to the movie
theater and with a blindfold on and just
listen to the movie don't do it
because didn't say well I was garbage
the biggest thing I want to point out is
even with the issues I have with the
story like I still want to get this game
at eight nine out of ten like I want to
like the atmosphere the characters the
that the gameplay
and let me say it again the atmosphere
and the attention to detail is so good
that it wants me to overlook the most
important thing about games which is
story and gameplay this game plays so
good its overshadowing the story right
you know I'm the kind of person that I /
I require good gameplay I don't care
about it the story can be amazing at the
gameplays but I'm not gonna get to the
game however based on what I know of you
I've seen situations where games have
really knocked it out the park gameplay
wise for you and then narrative Lee the
game may do something at the end or the
ending itself that you don't agree with
whether it be motivation whatever and
you have docked points from games with
the way games end in Howard how the plot
lines comes this is some of the best
games I've ever played okay okay so as a
result I'm just a game play it's the
attention to detail it's the atmosphere
when you you know you you're on your
horse going around like it feels like
you're in that area like you know they
show you what certain places in the
country looks like all flooded and so it
feels like you're in that area it's a
combination of everything the story as
of right now it's not it is an average
story to me it's not great but it's not
to the point where I'm like you know
what cognitum this story's trash it's
not like they don't make sense but okay
we'll go with that that's what I've been
hearing I've been hearing what that
people been saying certain things don't
make sense you know I'm saying so that's
what they got it they got it they have
thing let me get this to match and I'm
gonna get solved so let's get to super
sad shout out to Thanos is boss with the
tempest super jet BG is thinking just
because the story does something
different or unorthodox that means it's
automatically good not this case shock
value doesn't equal good it still needs
to be well written BG he comes oh but I
never said that's what made a story good
he's hearing things I said and he can go
go back and listen I said that's why
people don't like it I never said I
think it's good
I just met with Norah and another guys
later see you later
happy Father's Day bro so um yeah man so
so Saab I mean obviously you played you
were bout to go into the things that you
didn't like and what from what I said
and what we've talked about is it here
that justified in any of the things that
you don't like not that I've seen so far
I'm not far enough to say this and
narrative stuff narrative stuff is
really affecting me that way what I will
say is this well first of all one thing
that I forgot to mention and stuff that
I like that BZ mentioned was the
different perspectives the fact that
that you get to see things from a
different point of view apart from the
protagonist allows you to
have some empathy for what people's
people's motivations for what plan
you'll change that opinion yes in the
sense that you see it not that you care
but that you at least get to see the
point of view right it gets to the point
where that's a cool thing but then you
get to the point man again like do I
really like really like Phaneuf yeah so
the one thing I will say Dannemann so
this point feels justified to me and
again in my change later
it is pacing for this reason
talking the first game was a fairly
tight experience you had explorable
areas but it was still very tight and
and besides the pacing that story you
know drunk Neil druckmann said this
himself the story and the first one is
about love it's about somebody who's
lost sort of the ability to love because
of the things that he suffered through
and and done right allowing himself to
love someone again in that way and it's
story about how they come together so
that's quiet moments in that first game
all powerful are important sort of
growing that relationship right now even
with that said the quiet moments in that
first game are quickly followed by by
drama it's something come on you're you
never really feel for an extended period
of time that you're not in danger on the
first game in this game the there's a
point that you get you that you see the
changes they made in the game in that
they opened up sort of the court and I'm
not gonna call it an open world but they
bring things up a little bit it's like a
hub world right right it's like a hub
world kind of like what they did and
shout the cabassa because he mentioned
this and it makes thanks kind of like
what they did with Gears of War where
they opened it up a little bit and let's
say actually better than Gears or over
door yeah absolutely they did so what
what gets me about that is that
druckmann himself has said this game is
about hate so when I think about hate as
an emotion and hate as an emotion is
something that's irrational it's
something reactive it's sort of
something that lends itself to a story
that has like a frantic pace like you
did something to me I'm gonna get you
back I'm not gonna think about the
repercussions I'm just gonna go go go go
you know what's funny I'm sorry to
interrupt urine looks like it's the like
the pacing is weird sometimes like
you'll go from like stabbing someone's
neck in like one of those little scar
[ __ ] too you know let's talk about
what we did last Christmas you know you
know how you do in like open-world games
or RPGs where so yeah you like listen up
the world is coming to an end you have
two hours to save everybody and then
you're like cool no doubt yeah imma go
on these hundred side quests first you
know imma go fall in love and then I'm
gonna get to saving the world right and
it's so it takes you away from from the
gravity of the moment so in a game like
this I think it's almost detrimental to
it to not have that sort of more tightly
wound narrative and and and not allowing
you all the sort of Downton to run
around with because it takes away from
the gravity of I am hateful of something
I need to go rectify this right Annie
and it takes away from that in a way
that the first one didn't you
did the first one felt more frantic
right hate was quicker and it lent
itself to to all constantly sort of
being afraid of your surroundings even
in the quiet moments right I felt that
the first one due to the limitations of
the hardware push the narrative into
that into that corridor regain for sure
yeah because if you're looking at the
this hardware doesn't have those same
limitations so when you're able to go
into this open hub world I found it to
break the tension
I needed attention broken okay alright
um because then it turns it to a whole
different type of attention when you go
into exploring like I found myself a lot
of times just you know just what the
hell did I hear something yeah and I'm
going into a room oh I see a boarded-up
area and I'm going from point A to point
B so it didn't take away the attention
or that feeling of I gotta get revenge
I feel like I gotta get this done I
understand what she's talking about
because when it when they're having a
conversation about you for something
that she did it is the moments that
they're building because she's not a
child anymore right true right so when
she's building these experiences and
they're talking to another person
another NPC they're giving you a bond
because remember the bonds are the bonds
that you had before from the first game
is basically shattered right so you
don't understand where this new thing is
going so it's building up to that point
and in those quote-unquote quiet moments
they give you these benches to start
attaching you to this to that individual
in that same way ssin and and my issue
with that you're absolutely hundred
percent correct is that the banter
doesn't feel as meaningful as in the
phone no no it doesn't is random with
certain things is completely random so
professor look cute like mushy when it
has a visual cue and you have to hit the
button to hear that story then I think
that is intentionally put there but I
would agree with you if they did once
crazy stuffs not going down when they
did they all times you're a million
leagues ahead of me right and I'm
telling you from the view of a neophyte
right going into the game for any
individual that feels that I don't like
I thought the last of us the first one
was a perfect ending to that story if
you're going into that game like that
you know I kind of disagree with that
should be honestly this is what they can
do don't buy too late it would be so the
turbinate is a habit but how you drawing
mastering them if you don't like last
was two we got a game yeah we got a
super transfer you get to get up okay
with you King we've got Madame pom pom
with the final switch at Model View or
something I'm enjoying details wow we
forgot we did particularly a spoiler no
but people's names in the
talking about the super chef from
elemental Pio
does the marketing for this game mislead
the consumer the commercials are all
about le is that true I would agree with
you a little bit because you're
obviously you know we talked about
earlier there's different perspectives
they do kind of make you think that it's
all from one perspective but then again
like from from telling a story
standpoint I don't think they can really
tell you you're gonna put you you know
you're doing different perspectives so
they kind of have to do it that way but
you know that's just here the near there
we got a two dollar super shot from R&B
3 part 2 stories poorly written into the
bushes get it into the bushes in that
for uh for our man man and we got a two
dollar super chart from elemental peel
flashbacks in the bushes keep that into
the bushes and also had washes today I
don't like the Godfather Part two okay
so what I'm talking about the visual
downgrade don't watch the first reveal
trailer and then you can actually
understand what I'm talking about
um and it's not too it's not so bad I
believe those is running off for PCs and
or dev kits that have a higher bandwidth
and our stronger than actual PlayStation
4 Pro itself so when I actually got it I
said okay I see the shimmering I see the
thing that's a game now before I was
seeing something that wasn't a game
right now I'm seeing a game and I'm not
taking anything away from actually I'm
taking everything away from it
actually I'm giving you all that smoke
talk about the downgrade of the
graphical or fidelity of the game but in
the game is at a high fidelity mm-hmm
right yeah would I talk about it not
being truthful okay yes okay not being
60 frames per second
yes I was definitely go into that stuff
because that stuff I learned to
appreciate on another platform that I'm
not appreciating here
you thought you was gonna get smoke you
got this money but the story for any
individual that felt and I'm
wholeheartedly fearless if you didn't
pick up the game and you felt that I
didn't feel it needed a sequel if you
never buy the second one you go this
will never make the seco not exist until
they can exist for that's like watching
the first Lord of the Rings never
finishing the trilogy you'd say this is
this is the only you know because like I
said there's some movies and franchises
that I have such an emotional attachment
in when they come out with it like a
draw but I don't count to me perfect
ending super mega I agree with addict
the story just goes into the nonsense
territory not Cicero and territory into
the bushes however the game on a
technical level is incredible it's it's
you're beside you know I don't agree
with what King says on the actual
graphics I think the game looks
beautiful probably the best looking game
that's everything behave that's just me
and I just say this go look at the fur
that no and that that that's on a slow
look at and go play the game and then
you go go oh I see exactly what the flow
isn't how they tried to make the flow
stop you know is actually that was my
biggest thing when I saw the trailer
when she was flipped and she rolled and
she grabbed the brick and hit the dude
in the face and yeah you could do it in
the clunky version of that can actually
happen that they don't look like there's
not as smooth so let's stop like like
when we saw spider-man flipping and
doing this yet in the cutscene but in an
actual game oh yeah it really doesn't
happen in that form like that when you
actually do the vertical slice like we
want to get on and bang on everybody
else for vertical slicing to get their
game out okay this was a vertical slice
it looked way better in the trailer but
then when I got game I got a game
and appreciative for the game but let's
talk about the down grades let me get my
brother gaming forward say Happy
Father's Day Lord today is the day of
kings funny thing is my youngest is like
why you only have one day mom has you
beat by life bro gave it for it save a
salute to you very good to see you
brother
we got to take back Sunday's brother
take the Sunday bachelor I want to bring
this to y'all to now the next thing I
wanna bring to y'all on this subject
again is the reviews and there's a lot
of conscious look at that I got four
more dislikes not agreeing with me and
putting the four dislikes it counts
right you know it still counts yes we
got this review ball it's very you know
controversial um I wouldn't I want to
bring to your attention as far as
obviously why do you think this is
happening and then the other thing is
there was some very strict embargoes
about this game for the reviewers you
know saying so I think what we heard
initially was something to the effect
like like maybe you get the first you
couldn't talk about that the last 12
hours of the game in your review you
know it was very only really talked
about the first four hours you can talk
about the last 20 right you couldn't
talk about the last 20 it's very
polarizing the user scores right now on
Medicaid I mean right now it's a 95 meta
and the user scores a three point four
so this game is getting crazy bomb like
it by you can I say something that I
probably should say loves it's not a
spoiler anyone giving this game a 10 out
of 10 is a fraud
oh my god what is a away from you know
telling other people's a opinions wrong
or right but this game in no way shape
or form is a 10 out of 10 and not even
close and I just don't understand how
stuff happens where I'm at in the game
and no one even remotely trying to bring
it up in their review like even in a way
that is non-spoiler like they acted like
that didn't exist it's like they played
half the game it's like you know what I
think we're done
let's go review it Matt like I just
don't get it
let's get to it man we good dad all
right here's the day you know obviously
like I said it's getting bombed but I
want to talk specifically about these
embargoes then and our sin you can
review it we're giving you the copy but
you cannot make mention of the last 12
hours in your review how do you feel
about this that's it's just a really
weird way to do it you know if that's
the case then why doubt wait into yeah
you know or the date before it doesn't
make any sense to do it that way I know
Sony I saw something where they're like
going into chats and forums and like
striking Congress you know that's insane
to me I mean I don't know something with
hope law that is out the hole yo was it
and I was just like what in the hell are
these guys doing you know it's one thing
to you know if it's a review or if it's
you know using footage it's a whole
nother thing I think when it's just like
hey what about this part in the game and
you're just chatting about it you know
you do whatever you want mm-hm
it's it's and the review bombs come on
now I mean that's just you know I mean
balance to drop it down to whatever you
want it I mean I also disagree with that
it though to you know make it's a 10
right we rock at you know I mean so but
mm-hmm
you know it's you get those certain
outlets you know innocence you know like
you know shout out the season game you
know we always have to finish one of
ancient rules you know you have to play
the entire game all the way through and
you know to actually review the game and
it's how it should be so now not be
talked about the last part of the game
is insane also when you know apparently
you don't review code unless you agree
to those terms yeah yeah yeah it's it's
it's it's a weird weird way to do it and
I don't understand it just just it
should be just kind of across the board
you know a 3d like it's gonna come out
the day before this is when you're
getting the good reviews if you want to
go a week early and you all these you
know limitations on it then you know you
could get what you're gonna get and
people are gonna be up and you're gonna
get half reviews let me let me ask you
for devil's advocate sake
now we we do know that this game major
plots major cinematics were leaked
beforehand we do know this game had to
change release dates magically it was it
but my question is do you think because
of that that played into Naughty Dog's
decision to say okay you know what we've
got to tighten up on what they could
talk about or do you still think that
doesn't matter that the hardware should
be able to talk about the game as long
as they don't spoil it in its entirety
in its review part of me feels like that
was gonna happen regardless if it got
leaked or not because of this particular
game and what happens in the story they
don't want the bad stuff being talked
about it's like I said they only want
that oh my god this is amazing stuff
being talked about it's unprecedented
the amount of I've never seen a major
triple-a game get leaked in the way this
game has in my history of game at the
same time whose fault was that oh I
think I think the reason why I got a
leak linked was because the somebody
behind the scenes probably felt that
Sony was gonna hold this game back like
they did Miles Morales and said you know
what no no I'm gonna force your hand I'm
gonna leak out everything and you know
it is what it is so you think it's a bad
job yeah I think that because if because
remember it was indefinite that and goes
through Tsushima
right right right and if that doesn't
happen if the leak never happens do we
wait and you know because you know
cyberpunk um gets pushed back till later
you know it's it's a lot of things
that's in the moving parts and yeah but
it took it y'all would have took the
whole excuse of you know this situation
epidemic and all this other stuff is
going on and we're behind the scenes and
we're not there yet
you were took it and they said it's
coming out in November you would've ate
it and it would have been fine right but
then the leak comes out and then it's
like magical ready to go it's ready to
share yo you know what we're doin June
we were in definitely that's like you
know you tell your girl a date and she's
like yeah we're gonna get married I
don't know I'm thinking about it then
some moves come on she finds out that
you're not worth it
[Music]
the leaks definitely helped the game get
pushed out yeah you know regardless who
wrote who leaked it because we still
don't really know I'm not waiting to the
police station [ __ ] I might not play
a backpack it ain't coming out for the
PlayStation 4 Pro to hell with you
because it is the original question with
the Lisa stove do you think that is
dirty dog is justified by doing what
they do because I understood no I mean
yeah if it that we can come out we might
not even see it we're not be we might
not be playing it but why I mean they
say it was logistics and all that stuff
and apparently I mean they just if it's
out selling Animal Crossing and physical
sales only that's insane to say yeah
yeah don't yeah don't come at me with
that kind of knows you know I mean it
was right before that when JC fryer came
out and talked about the the working
conditions I mean there were so much
going against them
yeah you know I understand maybe a
little bit why they wanted to do that I
still don't agree with the tactic and I
think ATM you should just wait it should
just waited you know and just let
everybody you know Thursday right before
the game comes out or a night thing hold
on one second a day let me just get to
sue a chest shot to Brian Cooper the
Last of Us
- had audio issues where you couldn't
hear the stuff the characters were
saying unless looking in the direction
the entire game they still got that
because they got that in the first game
I remember that they start you know it
depends like III actually from my
playstation like be going listening to
headphones yeah I have to get like a
mini amp for my headphones because it's
very low so I I find that it's better
than in the first one but this sort of
happens like instead of you hearing it
directionally it you kind of have to be
facing that's not a pro issue that's
that's why I certainly wanted you to get
those ears in form sound for your ears a
brat man basically radio arcade but mm -
happy Father's Day little happy father
very no and of course we got oh fast
back from nlg Gary no Texas in a
building iron Lords show every Sunday is
a realtor data to allow great to see
damn from season gaming at the
roundtable if that is his real super
chat this Pixar animation topic is
running very long all those dead stage I
already wait a minute no switch topic
just be quiet anyway so let's get back
to attic man down daddy here's the day
you know oh I got another down thumb
thank you so added thing is um in
reference to the whole like we said we
talked about with the whole review that
the Metacritic the way Naughty Dog was
handling that you know what do you feel
about that whole day
he's eating pizza is in a building
alright so remember the whole embargo
process Naughty Dog told the reviews UK
you can review this game but you cannot
talk about the last 12 hours you got to
leave out major things we those things
cannot be in your initial review you
know do you say
that's justified do you disagree because
it's more like well you're not justified
and and I'd go out on a limb and say
it's scenarios like this that we should
completely discredit websites like
Metacritic whoa yeah because I like look
nothing it's not even Metacritic you
know medic right it's not the issue the
issue is outlets letting stuff like this
happen to put it all Metacritic for
these invisible Wars to be used with
these numbers it's like at the end of
the day it's not the first time stuff
like this has happened remember Metal
Gear Solid 5 mmm-hmm camp stuff yeah
that got sent out of tens - so you dig
this is fraud Ari you think do you think
oh it's it's the definition of fraud mm
like how do you how can you logically
review something you can only talk about
40 percent of the game oh so it's
impossible for so I feel like in a way
like people should be ashamed of
themselves that reviewed this game today
bars okay at the end of the day it's
like look like you're allowing someone
to manipulate you for like like like
look there might be stuff I would sell
out for but this is my mom my friends is
not one of them Oh hold Oh Hector come
before you said macho lordly he said I
disagree at it now remember we talked
about review embargoes and stuff and
remember I said back then that's that
you know issues like this is an issue
like you know and not only did they say
yo you can't talk about this you can't
talk about this you can only talk about
this perspective you can only talk about
like imagine like you know scale up he
said in there in the embargo you can
only talk about roughly around four to
five hours of the gameplay rather than
that go to the sellout of the individual
then because aren't you on outlet you
gotta respect the legal terms before you
you know even accept it aren't you hit
with the terms first yeah you turn it
over so you see the terms
yeah he's that I still love the game
I got half of I would expect the beads
bigger outlets right and to see
something like this I'd be like you know
what guys
thank you or no thank you no thank you
they uh will review it and our review
our complete review will come out when
it's ready all right but let's let's be
real now that would be the paragon of
virtue that would be the data that would
be missing out on your site having the
biggest most highly anticipated game oh
yeah you would be you would literally be
sacrificing clicks you don't sin this is
pure intake this is seasoned gaming
stuff I think I think IGN can afford
that but what a good day real quick what
they did first your last I think that's
how this whole thing works if you can go
around you have to have those clicks
first oh you know you're gonna you know
it's gonna cut you know your traffic's
gonna go up that's what they do
so one against that other sofas addicts
will fight on its own continue at it
that's what brings me to my next point
like look I'm not at for review bombing
games right if you're a fanboy and you
just don't like PlayStation got a hit
right not for that right but I am
definitely for reviewing bombing a game
if it's for a reason Oh company is
reviewing games based off of what Sony's
making them do let's be rare oh they're
not making them do anything but in a
world will we have to cover something
that we don't have we don't have food on
our table they don't cover it I can't
blame the outlet for trying to support
their family but I can't blame the
people given the restrictions making
them be under that those circumstances
to review the gonna fill out I felt like
oh here's the thing Sam won't say so
because they didn't discuss the second
half of the game addict but finish the
game they can't say it's a 10 a 10 and
if they did they was patient animation
and that's what I think is fine because
I don't know me they they finish the
game right so you can give your full
opinion and what you felt about the game
without talking about the end and it be
valid I get that part mop my beef with
it is this it's like if if talking about
the ending of that game or
last hours of that game it's imperative
to the story this is a story based game
this is not an open-world game where
thousands of side quests the story and
the Ark and how you felt about it is
imperative to your Tia final thoughts in
that game fridge it does not make sense
to 2/8 have a review embargo that's a
week out because the thing is the thing
about that is is immediately gamers once
they see in a review embargo that's a
week I was like oh my god has to be
great amazing games you say are you
implying something so are you applying
this logic is reading behind this
reasoning behind this they want they
want that smoke when they know that what
was god of war it was like two weeks out
or something like that let's be real
here and they wanted that persona with
the hardcore no kognito solve king they
they confident they releasing that a
week everything is the actual embargo
for the actual game they let you talk
about everything was up the day before
it came out one thing is these big
outlets they have the power to be better
and be like you know what guys
like I appreciate it you always give us
these codes early obviously to get early
but this is a story based game this is a
this is a direct continuation of another
story based game mm-hmm it's imperative
that we talk about this stuff because
like Dan said this is all click
motivated is the whole first meet first
thing and then the first digit to say
I'm gonna give it a bad score mm-hmm
then like it's a whole movement behind
that tent hmm you understand there's a
movement behind that tent right because
dudes in the heart even if they can't
afford it shout out to you bro ponies
you know pay Tuesday I'm playing it now
um they want it to be a ten no matter
what so those dudes are gonna gravitate
to that tent
ten let me see right and you know and
not knowing and not caring that he can't
talk about them that's 12 hours of the
game or the last seven hours or whatever
he can't do they just want to push their
narrative to feel comforted they just
want a blanket right so and they know
that but you want these sites to say no
we're gonna pass on the biggest game of
the year game of the generation on my
moral integrity group was they're in it
for the likes to cliques and everything
else that goes with it so at the same
time we can stand on this little pulpit
all we want of : when we're getting ad
revenues that's in the thousands I'm
talkin imagine looks like no I got a
salute lavrov shout out to love macho
shadow Lords he gave at that day he said
look I did the same with Final Fantasy 7
remake I talked about my experience my
thoughts feeling of all the gameplays of
music the graphics I lightly covered
story with my basic thoughts I got a
shout out Locke they're in the building
you know saying because here's the thing
and I've had out we've come across to
situations like this you know with um I
believe with Minecraft dungeons if
there's another game even macho with a
Xenoblade and stuff like that where
there's an embargo and obviously if we
want to hit that you know and get it out
fast get it done we will definitely get
the benefit of the clicks but I got a
salute that arises because a lot of
times they'll be like look I'm not
finished or because the embargo I could
do it but it's gonna be kind of rushed
out and stuff like that and a lot of
times loose it needs me to say look I
rather you wait so that we know you
finish the game when it's an entirety it
wasn't rush you got the full scope of
the experience and honestly it's
actually come out beneficial for us
because during that situation we've
either found out other things about the
game
and you can have like an impressions
article first and then a review you
don't say so to Lou to the riders I see
y'all in there we gotta get these super
chance real quick because we got to get
back on solving it on portal we got a
lot yeah let's get to the real topic
7.27 that's 2077 for Xbox series X
hinting release window for the consult
element appear with the $10 super chat I
respect your honest opinion addict
honest in quotations hey Smitty Smith
for the files we chat tell him Lord
addict it's like getting a plate of food
but can only talk about the brats of
bugs in the Last of Us 2 got stuck
moving Ellie had to restart way back the
game wasn't ready for release with date
with baby in doing four fives the 7-year
hell what they've been doing for 5 to 7
what they even do what the hell they've
been dovabear Bessie bear yeah I mean it
is on a pro oh my body with dancer and
what I said like I just to me it just
felt like I get it like this is the this
is the game right you want to be the
first out the door but iTunes always
first out the door like to me you know
sometimes I just gotta be better as much
criticism they get for their reviews is
like I I just saw like Alana Pierce put
up a video oh my god
excellent me James yeah not bro and and
bias and what that means
I advise you guys to watch that video by
a lot of peers about how reviews go down
and her personal experiences whether it
be IG out of these big triple a gay
there's a lot going on you guys have no
idea and it's one of those things were
great fantastic nobody's getting paid to
give up review numbers that's fantastic
but at the same time they still get
criticism fair or not for the axis that
they have right and and they utilize the
fact that they've been around forever
they the biggest outlet they're going to
get access so I get that
you know when it comes to a game like
this I don't know man I just feel like
standing on a square and just be like
listen i this is we need to talk about
this entire game yeah the embargo day of
even if people think oh my god I mean
the game is trash until it comes out
like whatever just do that and let
people speak about the game in its
entirety I don't I don't get it look I
play XO you guys have more authority in
me all I will say on it is I completely
agree with addict I completely agree
with you solve and then everybody the
whole table like it's just you know you
want to know the craziest thing be go
for it I still recommend the totally
cool all we're talking about is just
being able to review a game in its
entirety if you have restrictions on
what you can talk about it then I don't
think you should be allowed to review
the game yeah that's just me you know
then but hey I'm not knocking anybody's
hustle you want to get it first you want
to send me that Miles Morales are you
ready to break those we all sell for who
we love I will sell out we got the horns
we got the horns working QX 7 to the row
it finally worked we worked super hard
on that Krista you are out to addict
shout out to the graphic God we finally
got it straight down you got your horns
throw the chats up QX
there J clearly you see that there's a
black box behind it we go we found we go
work over there but don't you where you
got your horns blaring there's a great
big loves me that's me down real quick
oh yes well yes well if you don't stand
for something you'll fall for anything
throw it throw off the horns again we
got what welcome to the round
welcome to the realm sighted you already
don't salute that is awesome to see back
good to see now brother said oh they my
members that uh you know I don't know
how many you don't know but we actually
you know cuz you guys subscribe to the
to be a member of IOP you actually have
a chance of winning a an Xbox series X
later on this year is the who did
definitely sweepstakes sponsored by cat
daddy salute to the horns right there
that's what I'm talking about that's
what I'm for what's up to the next topic
let's please for t-shirt giveaway 324
people yeah ready for the t-shirt
giveaway season gaming for the t-shirt
you wait cold giveaway so the question
welcome your brother love it continue so
the question that has to be answered in
full in the chat is what was the
original release date for cyberpunk 2077
the original release date in 1984 Bessie
say hey I would be some reparation horns
I don't remember that okay we got drunk
and ninja and kids moves to two
different things is any of them right
I'm looking at the actual date now what
is the actual winning date is April 16
2020 no no I got oh yeah no elite said
he said April no you said April 20th 16
16 no it's senator elite said that kid
smooth you're wrong for say you're wrong
drunken Neji you're wrong then you're
wrong people acquit in the room just to
come back and go back hey what the
reparations since so congratulations to
you sir contact Lord dant Lord an if you
could put your your Twitter handle in
the chat definitely contact Lord an so
you definitely want to Xbox 1x he said
what I said a 1x what the hold the
Lord's a field is either be sequester
horns on his name's Lena
everybody definitely you know appreciate
all the support we're getting today with
members yeah you know every member man
put it put those logo there that was
sitting there waiting for horns to show
up I want every member put that shield
in that shot man put the shield's in the
chest welcome your brothers in Rome
exactly so we got we thought we do with
the business all but we feel got more
hold on who was it that wanted ships no
yes okay partner everybody we all
straight we all good yeah well good I
look out for one more shirt giveaway
shout out the Chris talking about a lot
going on these cyber Punk streets man is
2077
we got CD Projekt RED Betty announced a
delay to November this year for bug
fixing the game Bank listen your game
already got smacked in the face by the
last of us too so I stand your game no
listen what's funny is somebody shout it
from the roof that your game didn't
outstanding can I at least get the topic
offer cyberpunk definitely up in the
knees in the chat for kick in the bushes
a lot of Bedouin going a lot of bending
me beef Gordo but we got to get to the
town selectman either but they delayed
it
they said developer I had to call it the
investors they said the studio also
confirmed that the multiplayer is also
delayed and at the they spoke about the
place 85 and the next rock series X
editions that they will be free but not
necessarily not sure if they're gonna be
available at launch they said that a
more robust update would be later so
they'll look better on next-generation
consoles but not haven't confirmed that
the patch will be available the true
enhancement patch so um yeah they said
that that might be unsure undecided but
I said it could be 2021
and they said if not because it said
they still plan those things out so
again this is another Lee's I know King
you gotta get your balls off book before
I give the I gotta ask Dan because Dan
had Twitter on fire from one number to
Dan had ordered the Xbox one X
pre-ordered version of this game
cyberpunk condition he was very vocal on
Twitter about his disgust with this
latest favorite all delayed so I gotta
get Dan off first
there's where yes brother thing I'm
gonna have a game in a console but I'm
never actually gonna play the damn game
no I mean I bought I got two of them I
sold one I wasn't selling both but I I
was like you know what I'm gonna keep
this one I like it can't agree with me
but it I'm so tired of these doors I
understand what you're saying
but you said I mean you could take that
thing that they put out there that big
yellow stain okay angel face because
that's exactly what they said last time
the game is pretty much done we're just
working on but I'm fine get it done
you're at one buck in this game come
November oh I'm gonna be four man I feel
like how do we get these things work
they come out and they're like oh you
know temper your expectations shut up
hey what tempura know what you wish you
this things better be fighting thing
gonna be magical never be amazing Thanks
I'm tired of that stuff you know you
come out you get guys same yeah what
don't worry about you know temporary
expectations for the PlayStation event
no I'm giving you my yes you didn't show
me what you know you're giving I
rearranged my my funk
you know and now if you're gonna have a
console that never plays because I'll
have the exit well why even come out and
do that I mean they had to move
frustrating and I just don't understand
when I see that kind of stuff that you
know don't don't tell me that temper my
expectations ever you know I want
greatness why don't we joke it but
seriously for all the people who did
pre-order you know they got you know
buddy with the game II say yo we're
gonna give you the console right now not
a game come out later and you got the
digital for that's that's good they got
you it was this was you know because
this is what happened ain't said hey man
they might be selling it you know I
really want one I said oh no problem man
I got on there fine it's like 11:30 at
night I was like man you know I was
texting him honest like it on there man
he ends up getting like another now
everybody's got next to my house to be
though fine is disgusted huh but imagine
not having horns played for you though I
need a booth man to play solo to make up
for this
wait hashtag where the horns LP don't
treat us like the middle child
we want our [ __ ]
be honest with you guys you know
consider we've been getting so much love
you know we always say that we we put
back into what you guys gave to us we're
coming out with some stuff for the
members and patrons it's at the early
stages what we're coming up definitely
definitely shot to already what you got
from we got CD Projekt RED integrity is
in question triple a 10 not laser how
many times Rockstar plays how many times
Phil Dominus Maximus Spencer came
through through the bag and say no um
this is gonna come the game past day and
a king needs to get addict knees oh and
we need to move out here you know thank
you
I'm and shout out the film man I
understand he probably listened he said
you know what yeah man go call him put
him on the phone
listen put that in game pass push that
game back to November when we're gonna
drop around man so Dee you know can get
these knees and everything's gonna win
leave my man when he you know and then
the last of us to Kim
so you know what really nicely when the
last of us to came out and the
information came out that it be a Animal
Crossing mm-hmm I said oh boy I never
scared
no just holiday this holiday when we
both went our bets of king where we do
house right this is already in my house
I haven't knees mounted right listen
watch at your wildest thing about soft
knees is this right he lost already
Olli games is not back capac you gonna
be fries is a little bit more special in
the box up listen if y'all never got
West Virginia me you open the box nice
even like the country breathe I know
that I'm taking your left knee in the
box
we have he said he asked me King please
say that with the $2 tip sure all these
people joining screws my chances to win
dance-off did read that stitch you just
business he did read that but no listen
and all seriousness look forward to hit
that game pass I really thought that a
long time ago um I thought it was the
way that they were moving in the
background the way that the console came
out sorry Dan you know is all jokes but
um for them I think that's kind of shady
for them to put that console out but at
the same time they're probably saying
that well maybe for those people that
can't afford X you know series X or
whatever you know that they'd still have
this console mm-hmm but when I see
certain movements certain deals in
business is being made in the background
it's not just a console we're doing
isn't so it has to be
more to the whole deal right because the
deals is not being made on the other
side of the fence you don't have a
PlayStation version of a cyberpunk
console you understand so if it deals is
being made in one area what were you
giving up and what were you receiving so
it has to be a bar to type of system and
once they said I truly expected it to be
pushback I said if it comes out then I
guess it was gonna give him a couple of
months to to sell and then they probably
saw the metrics on a game pass right
right and then said you know what okay
so we can put it out for sale anyway and
we can put it in game pass and get the
engagement numbers to where it's gonna
be and we can still make our sales and
we can still get the engagement numbers
so we're still gonna pick up a bag we're
still gonna drop this console and
they're making money hand over fist and
I actually see that happening and I also
actually see it on West Virginia nice
talks gonna make the nice wave I got a
question for you like so now do you dig
dispositions them as the perfect launch
time is this is this foreshadowing this
November 19th it's foreshadowing the
date yeah
yes I believe that is the date that the
console come out that series X I don't
know about the PlayStation right all
right but I believe that's the day that
the X comes out um I also they believe
that's day and dating game pass and when
you can say we give you three months in
the box oh and you get cyberpunk you get
cyberpunk
you get halo you get whatever launch
games you get the Forza you get whatever
launch games first party that's in that
and you get uh what is it gears tactics
you get these games and then you have
another hundred and some-odd games in
there it's pretty much unbeatable lineup
oh so I honestly think that that's
that's the hammer in the nail that's
that's the coffin is ready just you know
put the core you know that that emoji
they be doing with the coffins
if you got a third me I'm in with these
two guys I'll split his left knee with
his left knee with you let's go into
game Pass day what's up will I think it
will eventually it becomes day and eight
I won't think everything back that I've
ever said bad about everybody I ain't
said it's kind of the same thing yeah I
think he's kind of the same mindset and
I'm always like there is no chance they
game big will do now I know it's where
they're going and we know we know that
right yeah you know I'm a hundred
percent on thought you know that's
perfect but I think they're gonna hit
that eventually where they're getting
those third-party games those big just
yet for long yeah let me actually what's
the biggest problem for game pass like
what is the biggest hurdle for like it
like if you evaluating game paths on the
outside right and your analyst in value
evaluating it what would you say is they
one critical flaw if fix will definitely
turn the tide I mean there there's
really not a whole lot wrong with game
pass it would be a third party title day
yeah but they're but they're still you
know they were getting like a triple a
title right they've got some third party
yeah that would be it I mean that that
would be Toby that would be every that
will that will open up the floodgates
for a lot of other companies that is
sitting on the front the metrics to it
it doesn't procure anybody to purchase
the game actually gives more incentive
to because it gives you that chance to
taste right so if the game is in game
past and you say 15 is it to 17 million
viewers is actually checking your stuff
out they actually have an opportunity to
check it out sealed numbers with
we meet whatever goals they are for
whatever reason without that would mean
Phil Phil Dominus would have to be truck
up Oh
CD Projekt RED expected sales would be
up yes
right and that's up and me know what and
and I honestly believe that to be the
case for one reason right right then one
reason I believe it to be the case a
lack of first party titles at launch it
would be it would listen that would be
epic yeah it would be epic I don't know
if I happen but I will say that it would
be abrogated I will say this I'm lining
up before your show with my just no
shirt with the tattoo well we don't get
banned because the nipples gonna be out
but that might just have Jonathan be
Phil might have done it for y'all but I
know who didn't play the points for me I
mean back compat home I need my horns at
4k 60 but for real I hope some of those
so it's caught what card feel feel so I
have so I have 2x 5 each other way VA to
great people joy to the rel for her like
Tomlin with the five costume check great
show as always my Lords Lord addict I
have a wheelchair for sale after King
lot of me talk we'll see I'll take your
knees if you want to real quick man is
about the cyberpunk thing where you at
it you know we had with this whole day
man because of this but I got no opinion
by this game
and addict to smokin lord Oh what do you
feel a man about this whole big like
would it win it setting up at November
you know I think it's I mean it's fine
listen I'd rather the game take take all
the time you with the game what I'm just
I it kills me that these studios keep
putting out these these release dates
knowing the amount of work they have on
the game like and you know like it's not
like you haven't been developing games
for twenty years like you know how this
works
don't put out a release table to a
hundred percent sure you can hit it it
just is weird to me like it's constantly
backtracking it's just weird but
whatever you know release the game one
is ready yeah that's that I don't think
this is close I don't think in the
harbinger of the release date of the
console foot for one reason from me I
think it's still imperative that that
series X hits before that PlayStation no
matter what and I'm I want them to drop
it in October to be honest also in
October he didn't say what holiday it
could be Halloween Halloween Friday
October 30th looks beautiful to me I get
that date I'm taking a week off I'm in
the same borough ready oh man I get the
date is when I'm taking off so for me I
think it's really important that console
comes out the floor PlayStation no
matter what I'll for you if cyberpunk is
ready you know whatever about you
whatever the case may be and I think the
console should come out in October ok
you don't matter if the price is
different I really don't they I think
price is gonna dictate sales so I don't
I don't care if it comes out a week
after the play they need every leg up
they can if a big third-party triple-a
game goes to game past day and date
possibly pushes somebody to put their
first party day and date on yeah now and
I don't know but I mean any possible
fortnight move the needle because it
just forced him to do whatever so
anything is possible but
I don't they're not ready for that this
is why you to me like I said what why
Shuhei is pushing those smaller games I
think that's that's how they start right
anyway Steve I need to go but always
like this was a blast at King storage
units are cheap now you might need one
for those needs good day y'all Betty's a
little brother
yeah I'll be at the end of the day I'm
always for the developer you know taking
time I filled all the people who you
know shot the dead people who reserved
that console who we don't wanted that to
be able to play it beforehand so in
September that sucks you know saying
there's just no getting around that
um you know the way I look at it look of
course I'm selfish I'm gonna pull a
Attucks world of course I was gonna want
it on a serious ecstasy toes improvement
but I gotta be a bit like I'm a little
tight that now with this delay that
doesn't guarantee the enhanced version
is oh look cuz they come out with a
statement say yeah it'll be naturally
boosted on the new console but not
necessarily you know we're gonna get
that that that mega patch joint that we
that we expects what might come later so
that's the only thing I'm a little upset
with and the multiplayer is my
understanding is still not gonna be
ready it's almost like almost acting
like it's a DLC in a sense and it's
still not ready so that's my last we'll
look that's all I got we move on to the
next thing when you got a chance Louie
with the $2 super qiat-ps 5 no limits
except that 30 frames per second which I
don't understand mate fill money bag
Spencer next look maybe we move on to
make it quick last time it we get up out
of here Lord King you want to talk about
PlayStation 5 pricing oh okay yeah so we
saw the PlayStation 5 reveal on the
digital
and the complete disk system what they
call them at the system at the Bulge
pause and a lot of people is running
around with wild speculation and pricing
and I believe because they keep using
the word premium and they keep using it
and they keep saying as a premium
product it's a premium product
anytime somebody is beating the word
like eccentric and premium and top tier
and top shelf they're setting you up to
pay a premium price you know and a lot
of people keep running around with three
nights coming in at 399 it's it's gonna
do that 399 um I honestly don't believe
so this is not Jaguar chorus guys this
is not a cheap CPUs this is not cheap
GPUs the SSD is not cheap the materials
on the console isn't cheap you're gonna
pay you're gonna pay for this console I
truly believe that the console is gonna
come in at five fifty for the the big
boy the with the bulge pause and the the
digital one is gonna come in at that are
$4.99 so I believe was gonna be 549 and
then I believe was gonna be $4.99 in the
launching I think that the standard ones
with the with the disc tray both of them
are coming at $5.99 and that's the
reason that Sony came up with this disc
list cuz they know that they're scared
of that price point they want another
price point to prevent to present to
their consumer base hold on to be this
ridiculous Alice Boston which I job to
be quick question if a horn plays in the
forest and no one is around to hear it
does it still make a sound
I wouldn't know either way about Gerald
Mac with the 2000 which I say something
brother please please we got to get a
horny movie to get to these regulations
because Billy but look man let's get it
to this price is real quick
Oh Lord damn man
where you at what are you thinking there
are places are five Whitnall console
revealed what do you think our pricing
is that I would say and it's five I
would say Protestant King 549 499 no
maybe maybe 500 and 450 okay lowest but
I mean really because they've got to put
it out there I mean that's that's if all
the rumors are true with Xbox coming out
and really kind of yeah undercut
everything you know I mean these
companies don't make the money from
their consoles there no that's not where
it comes from it comes from their game
it comes from the purposes you know that
but you've got to get people in you know
you know and Sony's taking a whole
different approach you know as far as
this next-gen it looks like and they're
there they're coming out and they're you
know you have to have this Hardware
right so you have to make it so people
you know it's accessible to people you
know and they're really tough right now
for love yeah yeah try to justify
anything more to 5 in this type of yeah
and so you got to really be careful with
what you're doing so yeah we'll see Lord
addict what's your price is what you
think it's okay you said the mic was
enough it's like I said I think the
price is gonna be $5.99 for both
standards yes and I think they're both
gonna be $5.99 and I think the reason
they made the digital version for the X
the PS 5 is because they've done $5.99
before and it didn't work very well for
them so I think they want to give
another price that's a little cheaper to
the consumers that beats microscope
thing is I don't think Microsoft would
have ever made the law cart if they both
were cheap I think that Microsoft knew
for a fact this is gonna be an expensive
console and I think as of right now we
could definitely do $5.99 like we can I
don't want to so if you think that then
what do you got the digital edition
PlayStation 5 coming in it I part of me
wants to say
$4.99 and then the other party wants to
say like I think could be $4.99 you look
I do think there is a point it just
depends on how much Microsoft wants to
compete if they drop theirs is $4.99
then Sony's going to have to drop the
digital version $4.99 or you know we
don't know how much research and
development Sony put into this SSD for
all we know like the PS 5 could be more
expensive I think it is we don't like
the thing is like we don't know how much
money it takes to make this SSD so maybe
that's the reason they have a digital
version is to have one of their specs
out is the same price as a series X but
you know that that that's reaching
reaching you know obviously that's
region region I have to say reaching
twice its to reaching momentum right now
okay before that we have a that psy
fanny-pack edition for nine years and
before that go get it go get it go get
it go get it shut out the season gave me
a go dad go go go get it cold y'all
don't get it
so my take my take is $4.99 and 399 mmm
for $4.99 for the hernia edition you
stupid and I'll be honest I think they
go 399 for the for the digital edition
oh my the fact that they released a
digital edition this is Sony we're
talking about it shows a commitment to
digital distribution in a way they have
not been submitted to beforehand so if
their hope and expectation is that they
will make money up on remember digital
purchases they're not splitting that
with retailers they're not splitting
they're getting a much larger cut of
every different sale digitally so if
they're thinking is okay we'll make up
the difference on that and see how many
people jump on a bandwagon if you see
like month over month same four-game
pass same for Xbox um even in turn
like people more people are just going
digital you know it's it's it's it's
gonna happen right at some point I don't
I don't expect though want physical
media to give away any time hmm but the
move to digital is real and I think
they're banking on that with this with
this with this discontent and you know
it is bold on their part because it's
not something I expected from them at
all but if they're gonna go that route I
think they go 399 with it and they just
Bank on digital purchases mmm and and
making PS now or more robust offering
yeah I mean look at the end of day I
care about what you saw I think that's
pretty much about price points to the
Billy says Sony doesn't sell digital
games digital game calls outside appears
now hundred percent exactly you trust me
trying to give up give away clean codes
is the pail which I think I think it's
five I think they try to position this
so we don't know if you're hearing it
I'm getting weird I'm hearing a feedback
[Music]
I need to mute though cuz yeah he's
definitely um shout out to Forte tough
people making more money on unemployment
and they made the entire year this is
true that is true look I know you two
retail kidding for it I'm not gonna
question you I'm just I'm just guessing
I mean I would just say hey if I had to
guess now you know the digital console
is to position themselves against you
know the lock are any type of
undercutting Microsoft may attempt I
think 500 if they're willing to take a
loss when we heard the manufacturing
cost was like 450 and then you know up
until five look that's what I got I mean
we'll see
I still think Lockhart could potentially
come lower than the UM the what you call
it the four and we got a see bad but I
definitely think it's strategy or on on
that joint for that purpose but uh saw
King you want to finish up when you join
it will be buddy well you good you said
no no no I said it that's what I believe
the price is to be when you start to
factor in all the high-end stuff that's
in a Playstation I mean I joke around
and said it made it on a budget and on a
shoestring they made strategic choices
for what they were going for and what
they were looking for right they put
their specs that guided to us
regular Xbox one X type of specs now so
now I actually you can see 4k
and you know 30 frames per second is
they target so that box is built for
land that we fled I mean the box is
built towards that you know Microsoft
box is built towards 4k 60 120 frames
per second
broken down to remove latency from stuff
so they trying to give control back to
the players you know back there Pat type
of information so the way they both view
are the industry is completely different
and and I believe the last of us showed
us where Sony's views are and will
always remain so to get that premium
experience and this is a premium console
guys from the look of it I told you will
look better than the exit it looks
better than X to me um from the look of
it we talked about how big this thing is
I mean it's ginormous I mean who would
think whenever your PC tablet these are
pcs now right you have your PC tower
your PC tower is huge
it needs that air inside we do not I
first of all I do not I don't care how
big you got to make their PlayStation
file I do not want my joint getting the
red ring of death day one all right I
put the five six fans inside dude you
got to do to keep that joint please
little bit quieter but you know from
messing up on my but yeah I believe that
price I believe you know the 599 and 549
states no doubt let's get this super
chest cut off we get out hold on a
second I was looking at something which
is the first con artists I see um for
our super chat I yeah I got it
I think will go like many like this this
the I think it will go like this series
X 499 series X with one your game past
399 Lockhart 99 Lockhart when your game
past 199 Wow yes Bo with the PS 5 parts
was purchased with coupons thank you for
saying something brother for $400 Xbox
news X or alias attained really annoyed
oh yeah before I go for the kill early
like man yeah that's crazy we got to get
this uh pole on here new IOP pole with
the recent controversy regarding the
last of us to review embargoes do you
think media outlets should be able to
review a game while being restricted
from mentioning the entire game in the
same review the choices are a yes major
plot spoilers must be protected in a
single-player narrative game be no must
only be listed as impressions or review
in progress until the game is ended or
see I don't care it's all fun and games
until you leaked my entire game on
internet you wanna get all we got some
super we got Jonathan B please we need a
PS 5 unboxing on king of statues that's
how big it is you could also play my
horns messy yeah a choice H for horns
super Lee we caught up to his last
t-shirt yes classy shirt once again
shoutouts Lord Anand and season gaming
whoa the final t-shirt giveaway the
question is before the announcement of
Star Wars squadrons by EA which was the
last game the last first-person
simulation shooter okay
in the same vein of squadron that was
released by LucasArts which was the last
what is the last first-person simulation
shooter game in that same vein as the
whole squadron released by Lucas by
LucasArts all right I see some answers
rolling in sub anything look right he
said who was
Rosemary's babies and first-person
shooter in the same vein why war
squadron squad the same same it's the
same type of vehicle based shooting game
there's boy names in it se stores
commando Battlefront - Rogue Squadron XM
Alliance army video browser Google baby
shout-out to Rudy ro ro da Romeo x-wing
alliant or I rode a salut for answering
these trigonometry questions on the
podcast we gotta do you gotta go go
check Lord Dan on Twitter low damage ego
once again put your Twitter handle in
the chat um and he will give you all the
information so you can get your season
gaming sure thank you guys once again
for participating and answering these
difficult questions I guess a little ro
salute the Lord dead of season gave me
the big cats comin to rocking powering
through three hours at making brisket in
between doing all types of stuff to
survive this lady pocket absolute
pleasure to have you in the room long
overdue wicked if I people find you what
you got going on sir yeah guys I really
again appreciate it in a huge
and for years I think the first one I
saw was Sam Sam Tolbert oh wow yeah I'm
back and forth I'll be having watch the
real bro appreciate ya I really
appreciate you guys you can find me at
season gaming comm just recently back
you know I'm hitter what yeah yeah SC
and Twitter other than that man check
out our site we got a lot of good
articles that are coming up with your
reviews unboxings you know all kinds of
stuff so it's been a great great time
today absolutely brother big pleasure
pleasure to have you best look to the
whole team Ainsley / the whole squad the
writing you know what's that loss game
you guys put them cress in the chat in
the chat for the legend babe you got a
there will be on rock there it is
Jonathan beat up feeling it got feeling
that right now bad about that right
that's not the army veteran for being
petty let his horns rock off you know
it's a celebrity game salute to the
realms to loot the season game and all
you guys man fantastic organization in
the big cast love what you guys are
doing man always a pleasure shout the
Teletubbies it's now I'm really angry
build the Lord addict man hang it
through we can define people fight you
find you what you got going on sir let
me go last because someone's using a
blender okay no doubt no doubt
okay here it no you actually sound real
fine you were good you actually good
alright what about a yeah I shut my door
I didn't want you guys hearing smoothie
means you just worry about those bought
that the box that's going to ship you on
Easter now I want the bone bristles all
I want is that all I want is the box
that's gonna ship them knees to meek you
want to buy that right there before you
go to UPS don't think you'd be
about America standing on right there
that's j-dub me you need money on top of
her to prefer to protect his knees at
Twitter Lord addict IOP
can find me on youtube at gaming addicts
you can find Twitter thank you
you can find me this Tuesday with Lord
King we're going to be live streaming a
ways out we're gonna be live streaming
that go on on the on this channel nine
horse podcast channel well when do you
want to start again key oh you are the
you control the time or whatever like I
told you I'll be you guys will be wham
bam in this and one shot yes so we'll be
starting at an 11:00 a.m. Eastern I will
be going live with the you know the same
setup that I Opie has with the the
waiting screen so I will be doing that
to give you guys enough time to come in
here and you know talk to each other and
get a good I so definitely stay tuned on
camera will not be on because I'll be
playing through my ex but my head said
alright so this excited DC you just got
it for the Jolly mister show you missed
a show it's over just a shirt from Dan
the mesh shirt for big baby weight loss
solve wicked if I people finds what you
got going on sir
you know I'll be working you know that's
what I guess yeah but I said a for
coming through a shout out for the
giveaway is a amazing have you on the
show big shout out Lord Burt Lord
Ainsley big shout out to drunken
conversations on the rooftop yes miss
that this year like yeah I know it is a
feeling yeah you know what I'll be doing
la la
very messy Lord King turning to be
around
Brittney's and sending people on Twitter
all day what's gonna be provide you the
foremost I would like to give a
shout-out to my 16 guests
Lord there that's gonna say Lord bugs
max there are bugs snacks no no cuz I
jumped in a chat he would and you always
bring the Thunder wizard sees Natalie to
merge guy oh if you like the shirts that
he got on please go to the teespring
slow where ever you get the merchandise
from and get those shirts you know
support because I season gaming is where
you know true integrity lies ass um so
it's definitely there and if you test a
watch is the level of professionalism
from the whole cast is definitely top
notch at all time shout out to Ainsley
both the sound up virtuous damn three
man show disaster no one they think
he'll win when feel so uh an easily hit
on his three-piece right yeah Twitter
King David OTW out hit giving out touch
whoa also an Xbox Live you know King
David OTW but if you want to see me on
PlayStation nation in a station and hey
PSN getting it and that's xbox 360 love
our old one I got a whole bunch of new
friends I see you added me because like
what now got like 10 friends hahaha
amazing what y'all doing over there I
see uh-oh but check that Bernie to chat
what's up guys season gave me at all of
the vitarelli today that's what's up on
PlayStation I've noticed a lot of you
guys ain't playing lots of buzz what's
the matter what's going on anyway
Oh
king of the statues listen go to Lourdes
game at net where you can get all those
reviews and all those opinion pieces you
can get old kale web talk with the king
you can go back there and watch this
right now watch the last word Neto and
Ivonne says you know it's very striking
when I tuned in because you know I much
I'm a little lurker i lurk on the net I
don't know the podcast I mean definitely
in the last 4k visuals in the campfire
destiny podcast
would you like destiny don't be ashamed
of it just just go show that support man
get over there show that supports know
you already know and of course right
quick oh man she's got a couple JD game
Antonella super chat just dropping
support must love that dodge its back
that dodge about 35 pounds which a great
show again last salute to you brother
always a pleasure topping it up next
year we got to meet up man we supposed
to link up this year y'all ready door
vibes and then we got JD gamer with the
$2 super chat hit that like button no
please man again Schluter dance with
everybody that tuned their Happy
Father's Day to everybody that pulled up
yeah you know say a fantastic show and
like I said we the support is just
amazing I really appreciate you guys on
that I'm out of here
everybody enjoy a Sunday and we're gonna
leave you with that little game giveaway
from the cave already join join us join
us hi I'm Lord King David of iron Lords
podcast and we're bringing to you an
exciting new giveaway this giveaway is
like none other
we'll be giving away an Xbox series X
that's right you heard me right the
brand new console launching from
Microsoft this year well this is how
you're able to be part of that giveaway
there's two ways
to get your name thrown in the Hat for
the raffle one become a member of the
realm that's hit that joy button hit
that joy button you hit that joint
button down at the bottom and you can
become a member and also another way is
by becoming a patreon member so you can
be part of the realm as well now this is
brought to you by cat daddy fat stacks a
member and lord of the realm a very
generous person that's in our community
and this community is beautiful so
remember you can have one entry by
hitting that joint button and becoming a
member of the realm and also you can
have another entry by being a patreon
now you said king what if I'm a member
of both well your name gets thrown in
the Hat two times so please like follow
us subscribe join or become a patreon
member or become both and your name is
in the Hat to get that Xbox series X as
to who did their for you
sweepstakes this is wonderful this is
something that I'm sure that you will
enjoy oh man